Sooo
Moin Leute, oder besser, wie die Tagesthemen sagen würden, guten Abend.
So, Moment, jetzt muss ich erstmal mein Mikrofon einstellen, weil Teams wieder ein Mikrofon
rumgefuddelt hat.
Hatten wir nicht ein Wupp-Musik, doch, sowas haben wir, haben wir auch immer noch.
Wupp-Music, haben wir immer noch, guck.
Wie laut, ja, Tegelizer können wir schon noch machen.
Ja, die Playlists, die sind leider immer irgendwie unterschiedlich laut, das ist ziemlich Gatschi-Roll,
warum auch immer, keine Ahnung, fragt mich nicht, ich wollte einfach das E-Mode unterbringen.
Leute, was ist heute, ist heute, Chat, Chat, die wichtigste Frage des Tages, sind wir
heute, sind wir heute, heute Weeps-In oder Weeps-Out, also Nummers, oder gibt es einen
Reifen-Stream, oh Leute, mit den, hört mir auf, Alter, das ist so schlimm, ich muss
euch was erzählen, also für alle, die es noch nicht, okay.
Weeps-In, alles klar, Carlsson, Dankeschön für den Sub, 29.000, ich brauche mal so langsam
aber sicher echt mal mehr Keks, aber nach dem Gold-Keks mit Kette gibt es nichts Neues.
Leute, ich muss euch was erzählen, mein Reifen ist kaputt, ein Reifen an meinem Auto ist
kaputt, ihr wisst ja, ich hab so ein ganz tolles, super modernes Auto, also wer das
noch nicht gesehen hat, also ich hab so ein, in grün, ich hab so ein ganz furchtbar neues
Auto von 2000, Baujahr 2000 oder so, und bei mir sitzen da auch immer die Grills drinnen
und gucken aus dem Fenster, die stehen auf Opel Agilas, das wissen wir ja alle, und der
Reifen ist kaputt, der, tja, und Leute, es ist ungelogen, ich hab, in meinem ganzen Leben,
ich hab noch nie einen platten Autoreifen, könnt ihr euch das vorstellen, ihr wusstet
gar nicht, was man da macht, ich hatte noch nie einen platten Autoreifen, so, also was
hab ich gemacht, so wie ich halt bin, ich bin auf Amazon gegangen und hab Autoreifen
gekauft, und da wird der erste sich jetzt schon denken, warum geht der auf Amazon kauft
Autoreifen, aber ich hab bei Amazon geguckt, und ich hab ein bisschen Tests gelesen, und
ich wollte mir jetzt ein, so ein Ding, wollte ich mir bestellen, so, irgendein davon, kleine,
so, irgendwie so, so, und die Sache ist die, ich hab bei Amazon geguckt, weil, weil, dass
schneller da ist, als irgendwie was anderes, nee nicht, nicht ein Reifen, ich hab vier
Reifen bestellt, vier Stück, vier Reifen hab ich bestellt, so, die Reifen kommen morgen,
am Freitag, ja das ist Amazon, das ist neu, so, morgen ist Freitag, und ich hab dir gestern
Abend noch bestellt, da hat er alles schon zu, so, also, heute ruf ich bei der Werkstatt
bei mir hier um die Ecke an, und sag, Leute, ich hab einen platten Reifen, aber bei der
Gelegenheit, können wir gleich alle neu, also alle Reifen neu drauf machen, weil die sind
eh schon alt, und dann hab ich denen gesagt, ich hab mir vier Stück schon im Internet bestellt,
die sind morgen da, wie kann man das am besten machen, und dann meinten sie, nein, das machen
sie nicht, und dann hab ich dann gesagt, wie, wie das macht ihr nicht, hä, hab ich jetzt
gar nicht verstanden, aber ja, irgendwie, was hat er erzählt, aus Garantiegründen und
bla und sonst was, da mag alles was dran sein, aber ich geh mal ganz davon aus, dass kann
man besser handeln, die wollen einfach nicht, und warum wollen die nicht, hab ich dann auch
rausbekommen, weil, weil, dass auch gleich mal über 50 Euro teurer ist, wenn man die
gleichen Reifen bei ihnen bestellt, ich mein, ich verstehe, dass die das irgendwie rein
kalkulieren, ja, die sagen, hey, Reifen bei uns gekauft, dann verdienen wir da noch was
dran, und so, das ist ja okay, ja, hätten die jetzt gesagt, okay, dann machen wir 10 Euro
mehr pro Reif, was eigentlich schon, aber egal, dann hätte ich das ja auch gemacht,
aber jetzt kommt der Hit, die haben gesagt, nee, machen sie nicht, und dann hab ich gesagt,
ja gut, was kostet's denn bei euch, was kostet bei euch die Reifen, was kostet's denn insgesamt,
ich hab ja im Vorfeld mal geguckt, ich hab ja im Vorfeld mal geguckt, bei Amazon wusste
ich eigentlich, dass man bei Amazon Werkstattbesuche buchen kann, wenn du bei Amazon, ich weiß
nicht, ob ich zeigen kann, wenn du bei Amazon einen Reifen bestellst, kannst du ein Auto
hinzufügen und einen Service Provider, du kannst Werkstatttermine bei Amazon buchen,
das war mir neu, ich mein, woher soll ich das auch wissen, so, du kannst Werkstatttermine
bei Amazon buchen, so, und jetzt, und jetzt ist halt das Problem, ich hab mal danach geguckt
und das ist wahrscheinlich eh schon nicht das billigste, also ich hätte bei Amazon
ziemlich genau 300 Euro bezahlen müssen, für vier neue Reifen und inklusive Einbau,
also irgendwie 200, bla, noch was, die Reifen, das ist wahrscheinlich auch schon ziemlich
teuer vermutlich, weil ich weiß nicht, ich kenn mich, ich hatte wie gesagt immer, ich
hatte in meinem Leben noch nie, 50 Euro sind eher 80 Euro Montage, ich hatte in meinem
Leben noch nie einen Plattenreifen, Credo, Dankeschön für den Sub, Selbstwechsel, Moment,
mir geht es nicht um das Wechsel vom Rad, sondern um den Reifen, das heißt, du musst
den Reifen ja von der Felge machen und den Reifen dann wieder drauf kriegen und so, das
mach ich bestimmt nicht selbst, so, und, dann hab ich die gefragt, ja, also wie sieht's
denn bei euch aus, und dann meinten, ja, er könnte den Reifen jetzt bestellen, ja doch,
gibt's bei mir, äh, äh, äh, das gibt's, gibt's bei mir, komm ich, komm ich ja gleich
so, sie könnten den Reifen jetzt bestellen und dann kommt er vielleicht am Samstag, äh,
da kommt er vielleicht morgen schon und, aber Termine können sie mir eh nicht geben, weil
sie sind ausgebucht und, ja, dann wird's wahrscheinlich Montag, da hab ich, wollt ihr mich verarschen,
ich bestell mir im Internet Reifen, die sind frei nach da und ich, was, was, was ist denn
das hier, so, geh ich woanders hin, aber ich hab die vorher noch gefragt, wie sieht's
denn aus, ähm, was kostet's denn bei euch, was kostet, was kostet es denn bei euch,
so, wohlgemerkt, bei Amazon bin ich bei insgesamt 300 Euro, ziemlich, ziemlich genau, ähm,
und dort die wollen 380, what the fuck, nicht nur, dass die noch fett raufhauen, die Reifenpreis,
sondern insgesamt auch nochmal, das seh ich nicht ein, das mach ich nicht, ich mein,
ich bin normalerweise nicht so, mir kommts, wenn die Qualität und so, mir kommts da normalerweise
gar nicht so drauf an, aber den Preisunterschied und vor allem da noch mit diesem gönnerhaften,
ähm, so nach dem Motto, man dürfte sich glücklich schätzen, so, das haben die so nicht gesagt,
ja, ich sag's nur, aber das hatte ich den Eindruck, man dürfte zu ihnen kommen, die
können nicht mal. 380, naja, 380 quasi, also ich vermute mal, was da dabei ist, 83 Euro,
die müssen die alten Reifen runter machen, von den Fällen, die müssen die neuen Reifen
drauf machen, und dann wieder ans Auto machen, inklusive Reifen, das gleiche hätte mir Amazon
auch gemacht, für 300 Euro, interessiert mich die alten Reifen entsorgen, die lasse
ich in der Garage liegen, und alte Reifen entsorgen, wär auch dabei gewesen, ja, tatsächlich,
warum ist 80 Euro Aufpreis versus das gleiche in Ordnung, warum sollte ich 80 Euro mehr
bezahlen für was, was ich exakt das gleiche für 80 Euro billiger krieg, der einzige Grund,
warum ich nicht bei Amazon gekauft hab, ist, ähm, weil das irgendwie um die 30 Kilometer
weg ist, die nächste Werkstatt von denen, die sie bei mir haben, und ich komm damit wahrscheinlich
nicht hin, dafür zahlt Amazon keine Steuern, aber die Werkstatt, die sie vermitteln, bezahlt
Steuern, das ist doch überhaupt keine Erklärung, das ist mir doch unter, ja, Amazon vermittelt
dir, Amazon vermittelt, guck mal, wenn du bei Amazon Reifen kaufst, kannst du sagen,
Service Provider, da addest du dein Auto, also machen wir doch mal hier, also hier, bestes
Auto, wahrscheinlich das alte, keine Ahnung, ich hab keine, kein Schimmer, weiß ich nicht,
Confirm, so guck mal, und die haben, die haben hier in der Nähe, haben die nur sowas
und das ist alles ziemlich, ziemlich weit weg, also ich sehe es insgesamt nicht, ein
80 Euro mehr zu bezahlen, Leak, ja, das ist auch furchtbar geheim, das hat mich schon
ein bisschen gestört, ich geh einfach, also ich hab denen jetzt gesagt, mal gucken, ähm,
nächste Woche, ich meld mich noch mal, das will ich nicht, ja, Moment, 86 Euro für ein
Reifen, ja, also wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, das ist auch der falsche Reifen, den ich ausgewählt
hab, den da brauch ich, so, ja, du musst jetzt sagen, hier irgendwie, ich glaub das
kann ich, ich glaub das kommt sogar hin, du musst sagen, 4 Stück, 4 Stück, dann kannst
du Service Provider, ja, oh, Leute, ich schwör, irgendwas, das sag ich auch wieder im Schall,
ich hab gestern irgendwas anderes ausgewählt, das war billiger, das war, trotzdem, trotzdem,
sind immer noch 60 Euro mehr, das war ein anderes, das war ein anderer Reifen, ist egal,
trotzdem 60 Euro mehr, warum, warum soll ich 80 Euro mehr bezahlen, wenn ich exakt
das gleiche für 80 Euro weniger krieg, versteh das nicht, ich hab gesagt, ich meld mich
noch mal, mal gucken, was, reifenvorort.de, das gucken wir jetzt noch mal, geben sie eine
Reifengröße ein, boah, shit, ähm, äh, was ist das, 160, 65, ne, 165, ne, 160, glaub
das da, ne, 160, 65, oder, 160, alter, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie meine fucking Reifen
heißen, die ich brauche, was hab ich denn hier eben ausgewählt, so, 165, 60, ok, ok,
das Ding kann kein Slash, hier, das da, Reifensuchen, Alufelgen, ich glaub es geht los, und wo wählt
man da jetzt, ok, ich wähl jetzt mal random irgendeinen Reifen aus, achso, ok, ihr Standort,
der Profi-Partner, das muss ich mir mal bookmarken, das ist nicht schlecht, ok, und, haben die
auch online, online Terminvergabe oder so, ne, oder, die 9-11-Klinik, oder, der Adnan
Ahmed, Ahmed, Postleitzahl liegt, ja, haben die, haben die online irgendwie so Termin-Buchungen
oder so, ne, oder, ja, anscheinend, anscheinend nicht, egal, ähm, scheiß drauf, warum, warum
ist die Musik heute so aggressiv, ist ja doch gar nicht, Leute, soll ich lieber, soll ich
wieder super, huge, huge entspann, wie krieg ich das wieder weg, soll ich wieder huge relaxing
Mario-Musik anmachen, Sekunde, wo haben wir's, soll ich das lieber, Toxy, danke für den
estab.
Ticken lasse
Gut da können wir jetzt ja zur eigentlichen sache übergehen
Ich mach mal meine vm an
Und wie m wie die coolen leute sagen
Wie spricht ihr das aus vm wäre oder wien wäre oder oder?
wer
Oder was auch immer also ich sag ganz deutsch vm
Vm wäre sage ich
Wim wäre okay ich sag vm wäre
Semper video werde es wäre wird schon sagen vm wäre
Wobei ich kann das nicht
Da spricht auch schaden wäre immer so geil aus in
Diesem video noch ganz kurz
Hat der ekea sensor funktioniert ja hat er staub ich muss in update machen was hier los
Arne das ist noch der browser vom handy
Er hat jetzt einfach den keyring aktualisiert und sonst nix oder was was das für ein update
Hek weight wir machen trotzdem update
Vm okay ich sehe die meisten leute sprechen das auch vm wäre aus so muss es sein
So ja was lustiges erzählen von der arbeit
Wir haben ja das habe ich das habe ich euch ja schon ein paarmal erzählt wir haben ja mittlerweile windows defender also für alle
die es nicht wissen ich erzähle es jetzt noch mal
Weil die sich wissen wir haben mittlerweile windows defender auf der arbeit
auf linux server
Das ist kein witz windows defender auf linux server
Der password leaker genau
so und das ding
hatte irgendein bug
Und der bug hat sich sofern geäußert
Dass das ding memory geleaked hat
Und da haben auch ja ist so wenn das wie gesagt wenn es gibt es gibt windows defender für linux also nenne ich microsoft
advanced threat protection nennt sich das dann
Sag ich gleich was zu und
Das ding hatte irgendein memory leak
Und daraufhin musste unser support jetzt zwei wochenlang
Mächtlich den windows defender neu starten dass das memory leak nicht den ramp voll frisst
Und wir haben uns alle gefragt wie kann das sein
Dass das ding ohne update also ohne also ohne
Das ding ohne update also ohne also signatur updates ja aber
Ohne richtiges update warum hat das ding von heute auf morgen ein memory leak ohne dass es geupdated wurde
Und wisst ihr was jetzt rausgekommen ist und das ist der absolute hammer
Das ding ruft sich signaturen ab
Das ist ja schön und gut aber in diesen signatur update sind auch patches drin
Also die können das ding quasi on the fly
Patchen über signatur updates
Das ist quasi die remote code execution für microsoft höchstpersönlich
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen so einen scheiß
Installieren wir auf unseren kisten
Und die finden es auch noch alle furchtbar geil
Remote code execution as a service ja also quasi Ritze
Warte mal Moment ich sprich das remote code execution as a service
Rc rc ea's
Ritze
An wie dünnsches Ritze
War wie kann man so ein schwachsinn überhaupt nur installieren das ist mir vollkommen unangenehm
Das ist mir vollkommen unbegreiflich
Alter Leute das verstehe ich nicht
Aber big stonks manager finden das geil bei uns
Leute big stonks ich muss euch noch was erzählen ich gucke jetzt mal kurz in meine broker app
Ich glaube ich hab mittlerweile schon ganze 50 euro mit meinen stonks
Oh
Ich hab nix gesagt
Jetzt sind es weniger
50 euro mit meinen stonks gutgemacht
Ja
Soll ich euch was sagen?
Heute Mittag war es noch 50 euro plus
Wisst ihr was es jetzt sind?
155 euro minus
Tja Pech gehabt
Na gut weiter im Text
Reicht ja durch Geld verlieren
Super massive reich
Wie kann das sein? Das ist heute Mittag noch 50 im was ist das?
Was soll das?
Anzeige ist raus
Alter
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal genauer angucken
Das ist ein Anzeigefehler
Ich sehe es nämlich gerade
Die Skalierung ist mega im Arsch
Das glaube ich das stimmt nicht
Na egal
Also wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich glaube in dem Fall dass es wirklich ein Anzeigefehler ist
Aber die Skalierung stimmt überhaupt
Der ESP hat normalen nur 3 Volt
Oder hält der auch 5 Volt vom Ikea?
Der hält auch 5 Volt aus
Wenn du einen D1 Mini hast ist das überhaupt kein Problem
Also die meisten
Also die allermeisten der normalen Entwickler Boards
Halten beides aus
Wo man vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtig sein muss
Wenn man so ein nacktes ESP Modul kauft
Mit 5 Volt betreibt
Also halten die das aus
Ja
Wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt das gibt es
Advanced Threat Protection
Kennen sie sich das?
Microsoft Defender
Advanced Threat Protection
Für Linux
MS, ATP, Linux
Da
Microsoft Defender für Endpunkt
Unter Linux
Doll
Dass es das gibt
Da sind wir alle glaube ich sehr erleichtert
Wer kaum auf die Idee
Na ja da muss ich ein bisschen
Die Hintergrundgeschichte warum wir auf der Arbeit
Windows Defender
Auf jedem Linux Server haben
Folgendes
Das ist absolute Business Strongs Logik, die könnt ihr wahrscheinlich nicht nachvollziehen, wenn ich es euch erkläre, aber das war so, das ist Business Manager Denkweise.
Also, wir hatten einen richtig größeren Security Vorfall, weil ein Windows Fileserver übernommen wurde und irgendjemand hat da seine Admin Credentials drauf gespeichert.
Das ist die Kurzfassung, er hat auch nicht wirklich seine Admin Credentials drauf gespeichert, aber so ähnlich. Ich erkläre es euch jetzt anonymisiert und in Kurzform.
Also, irgendeiner hat einen öffentlich zugänglichen Windows Server gehackermant von uns und hat darauf einen Admin Account gefunden.
Mit dem Admin Account hat er dann Zugang gehabt, was AD und sowas angeht.
Und auf einmal hatten wir halt irgendwie einen Nicen Verschlüsselungsdroianer am Start auf dem Fileserver.
Aber wir hatten Backups und das alles. Es war kein großes Ding, also das hat zwei Tage gedauert, dann war das alles wieder in Ordnung.
Eigentlich ist es nicht so wirklich wild gewesen. Zumindest daraufhin hieß es, ja wie kann denn sowas passieren?
Da sind wir überhaupt nicht richtig geschützt und dann haben die sich, weil es ja ein Windows Server war, da haben die sich Consultants von Microsoft gekauft.
Und die Microsoft Consultants haben ihnen dann Windows Defender verkauft und gleich auch Windows Defender für Linux mit.
Und das war so krass, dass die nicht einfach nur gesagt haben, wir machen auf Windows Server, auf Linux Server, Windows Defender,
die wollten allen Ernstes, dass ich Windows Defender auf mein Linux Arbeitsplatz Notebook mache.
Zum Glück sind wir da ein bisschen drum herum gekommen, weil wir haben eine Testinstallation gemacht und das Ding hat einfach dafür gesorgt, dass du dich nicht mal mehr einloggen kannst.
Deswegen haben wir dann gesagt, gut, sonst dann halt nicht, aber ja.
Also sprich, wir hatten Probleme mit Microsoft, die einzigen Systeme, die die ganze Zeit sicher waren, keine Probleme waren unsere Linux Server.
Daraufhin hat man sich Consultants von Microsoft geholt und Microsoft Consultants haben Microsoft Software verkauft.
Richtig fivehead die Jungs da.
Da haben wir das am Start.
Das ist wirklich so.
Also wir haben einen täglichen Task gehabt, Neustart Windows Defender.
Da hat sich unser Support auch sehr drüber gefreut, weil die machen sowas ja immer sehr gerne.
Ich habe keine. Ich habe keine russischen Stonks.
Ich habe eine Welt, wie heißt das Index ETF oder sowas.
Deswegen ist das sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass der auf einmal minus 160 Dings ist von nichts von von quasi plus minus null auf einmal.
Deswegen glaube ich immer noch nicht, dass die Anzeige so richtig stimmt.
Wir können den kurz kurz gucken.
Kurs. Finanzen.
Wie keine Daten. Warum gibt es da keine Daten?
Minus eins. Heute war ein wilder Tag.
Okay, na ja, die Börse Frankfurt, was sagt die?
Also es sieht jetzt irgendwie nicht so aus, als wäre das so wahnsinnig viel weniger geworden, oder?
Das ist hier mal mittags kurz.
Schatz Stonks.
Keine Ahnung.
Na ja.
Ja, dann kann es schon mal passieren.
Das ist ein ernstzunehmender Faktor.
Was? Gestern hat das Mainboard von meinem 3D Drucker angefangen zu brennen.
Das war richtig monogatisch. Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Warum hat das angefangen zu brennen? Hast du das Ding irgendwie überlastet, überhitzt oder war es einfach billiges China-Chinesen Zeug?
Ja, man sollte nicht unbedingt 5 Volt an den 3,3 Volt Pin dran machen.
Ja, das also das trifft aber nur, wenn man den nackischen ESP hat und da dran muss.
Und bei den Boards über USB ist gar kein Problem.
Und bei den anderen Boards hast du 3,3 Volt über 5 Volt.
Das funktioniert. Und die Cheap Air O-Pins sind eigentlich 5 Volt tolerant bei den meisten Boards, die du dir kaufen kannst.
Also der D1 Mini hat kein Problem.
Die ESP2866, der NodeMCU, der verkraftet glaube ich bis zu 12 Volt Input.
Also das Board hat einen Spannungswandler. Der wird aber ziemlich warm.
Tja, so ist das halt, wenn das die richtigen Leute entscheiden.
Oh, das ist ziemlich MonkaS.
Ja, wenn du 12 Volt auf den 3,3 Volt Pin machst, dann raucht das Ding.
Du darfst nur 12 Volt auf den Input Pin machen, der dann danach über den Spannungswandler geht.
Also die China-Chinesen-Dinger sind mir schon abgeraucht, Leute.
Ich sag dazu nur, hat jemand zufällig das Ding zur Hand?
Top Clips?
Wo ist das Smoke Clip?
Smoke?
Es hat geplinkt. Das plinkt ganz kurz. Okay. Habt ihr es gesehen? Ich hab eben nicht hingeguckt.
Achtung.
Wow, wow. Smoke. Warum?
Bill, also so viel zum Thema billige Spannungswandler auf Amazon.
Guckt es euch an.
Seht ihr das hier?
Rauch.
Seit wann fährst du eigentlich wieder?
Ich fahre so gut wie gar kein Auto.
Deswegen hatte ich in meinem Leben auch noch nie einen Plattenreifen bis jetzt.
Aber manchmal brauche ich das.
Und ich bin am Auto, also ich hätte es noch nicht mal gebraucht.
Ich bin am Auto vorbeigelaufen.
Habt ihr gesehen? Der Reifen ist platt.
Billige Spannungswandler von AliExpress.
Nee, lieber, wie heißen die Dinger?
Stepdown-Dings kaufen.
Da hast du nicht das, das gesmoke wie in dem Clip.
So, aber halbe Stunde geschwätzt.
Vm geupdatet.
Lass mal kurz rebooten.
Wir sind ja heute hier zusammengekommen.
Das fängt jetzt wie in der Kesche an.
Prager.
Wir sind heute hier zusammengekommen.
Um die Etiketten, um den Etiketten Label Editor weiterzuwenden.
Prager.
Schau mal was von Direktus als Backend Assis, nein.
Was sollte ein Backend Assis Service sein?
Hab ich ja nicht gehört.
Reifen kann man auch flicken lassen.
Ja, es kommt drauf an anscheinend, wo die kaputt sind.
Aber ich werde die austauschen.
Ich werde die austauschen.
Die sind eh schon uralt.
Ich meine das Auto, Monoscheiß.
Das Auto ist von 2...
Baujahr glaube ich 2000.
Und die Reifen, die sind wahrscheinlich auch.
Von 2000 oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Was weiß ich.
Kann man glaube ich schon mal austauschen.
Ja, alles immer.
Was meint ihr?
Wie oft ich damit fahre?
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Also, ich muss Wüstelstudio Code aufmachen.
VS Code.
So, also wir sind...
Was?
Writing Login Information to Kitsch...
Ja, gehen wir nicht auf den Kicks.
Also wir sind stehen geblieben.
Wo sind wir denn?
Repos?
Nee.
Writer?
Label nicht Print.
Labelchamp hieß das?
Nee.
Wait a minute.
Labelchamp.
Repos?
Labelchamp?
Ah, Repos Labelchamp.
Ja, manchmal bin ich da ein bisschen verwirrt.
Wo ich denn was hingelegt habe.
So, ich habe auch schon ein Shit Repo gemacht.
Pulle ich aber nicht.
Das habe ich zerstört.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgebastelt und ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Deswegen, das werde ich nicht pullen, den aktuellen Stand.
Ich habe das einfach nur gepusht, dass ich im Zweifelsfall für Sachen, die ich jetzt
nochmal machen muss, auf dem zweiten Monitor abgucken kann.
Cheaten quasi.
So, also wir sind stehen geblieben bei folgendem Stand.
Wir haben immer noch diesen komischen Kreis.
Der ist relativ sinnlos.
Das Monorepo, genau.
Carsharing.
Wem soll ich denn das sharen?
Der Preischamp ist down.
Da war mir jetzt zu anstrengend, den Crawler und alles zu pflegen.
Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Wir können Text Input machen, glaube ich, irgendwo.
Also, wir haben einen Editor für Text.
Übrigens, wir haben schon relativ responsive Layout.
Das ist noch nicht wirklich perfekt.
Aber, schon mal ganz gut.
Also, wir können Text einfügen in verschiedenen Farben.
Wir können den Text vergrößern, verkleinern.
Wir können den Text rotieren.
Und ganz furchtbar eklig machen, aber das machen wir ja nicht.
Also, das funktioniert.
Wir haben eine Suche für Icons, die man einfügen kann.
Und die kann man auch skalieren und sonst was.
QR-Codes kann man einfügen.
Jo, das war's im Prinzip. Mehr ist da noch nicht.
So, und was wir heute machen, da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, in welcher Richtung wir anfangen.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal mit was relativ Praktischem an.
Und zwar, dass die Labelgröße hier noch mal eingezeichnet wird.
Weil aktuell ist es ja so.
Du weißt ja gar nicht, wo das Label ist.
Ich meine, das Label könnte überall sein.
Wir machen aber vorher noch mal eine Sache, Icon-Browser.
Mal hier, LG oder MD.
Mal ein bisschen weniger.
Guck mal, so ist besser, oder?
Da sieht man mehr.
Jetzt sind die Dinger ungefähr gleich groß.
Nee, wisst ihr, wir machen was anderes.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal ausprobieren.
Wir stylen mal die Scrollbar im Chrome.
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Welche Nutzen hat der Label-Champ?
Man kann Labels designen und dann kannst du sie ausdrucken, wenn du einen Label-Drucker hast.
Das mit dem Ausdrucken haben wir schon ausprobiert in einem der vor, vor, vor, vor, vorletzten Streams oder so.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, also ursprünglicher Plan war, ich wollte Draw-IO embedden oder Excali, Excali-Dings, Draw oder wie das heißt.
Das gefällt mir aber nicht mit der ganzen iFrame-Embedded-Geschichte.
Und ich wollte schon immer mal ein bisschen JavaScript, so Image-Editor-mäßig was machen.
Da bietet sich das jetzt an.
Ja, und dann hast du hier oben einen Drucken-Knopf und dann kannst du deinen Label drucken.
Oder du kannst deinen Label speichern oder laden oder so.
Aber erstmal machen wir den, machen wir den Editor.
So, ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt, jetzt probieren wir mal was aus.
Das wollte ich schon mal.
Chrome Style Scrollbar.
Style Scrollbar.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Massive Scrollbar Style.
Kann man Inhalt von QoR ersetzen? Nee, kannste noch nicht.
Musste aber später können, weil sonst Massive, Massive Useless.
Also, Style.
Moment, ist das überhaupt ein Chrome?
Ja.
Hat jetzt aber nicht wirklich die Scrollbar gestylt, oder?
Den Style, der also kopiert, das ist veraltet.
Na, das ist ja auch immer gut zu wissen.
Keg Weight.
Was ist denn der richtige Style?
Webkit Scrollbar.
Schauen wir mal.
Das geht nicht.
Muss ich jetzt mal vielleicht refreshen?
Hat das jetzt was gestylt?
Nee, oder?
Wir probieren mal was aus.
Also, Breite 20.
Nee, das greift nicht.
Warum nicht?
Ach ja, der Chat ist im Weg, ne?
Ja, mach mal, ich mach den Chat hoch.
Ob in die Eck.
Ah, in die Eck kommt der Chat jetzt.
Äh, warum geht das nicht?
Icon Browser.
Ah, weil das von dieser doofen Virtualist ist.
Damit geht das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Da müssen wir das, da müssen wir das noch mal irgendwann selbst machen.
Und nicht diese, nicht diese Virtualist Geschichte verwenden.
Da müssen wir das mal selbst machen.
Nicht jetzt, weil da habe ich jetzt nicht die Muße dazu,
so eine Lazy-Loading-Liste zu bauen.
Aber, äh, das ist natürlich kacke.
Was ist denn, wenn ich das Global mache?
Ist das dann jeder für jede?
Scrollbar.
Ja, jetzt geht das.
Wenn ich das Global mache, ist alles gut.
Aber ich will diese...
Alter, sieht das beschissen aus, man.
Okay, wir können auch mal gucken, wie man das Ganze stylt.
Also, keine Ahnung, äh, Scrollbar.
Kann man da eine Höhe angeben?
Ich wüsste jetzt zwar nicht, was die, was die...
Nee, die Höhe macht nichts, das ist beknackt.
Keine Ahnung, 20, 10, 15.
15.
Boah.
Hey, das sieht gerade mal so schlecht aus hier.
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz, ganz stylisch mit diesem...
Ding.
Mit diesem Nibbel da.
So, Background.
Ähm, RGB.
Sowas da, perfekt.
Ach guck mal, da sieht man sogar den Hintergrund.
Kommt aber auch schlecht.
Fühlt ja echt ganz nice.
Ähm, was ist denn das da?
Nee, das ist zu hell.
Hat die Virtualist eine Klasse dran?
Nö.
Ja, intern, irgendwas random.
Random heißt das, das ist total bescheuert.
Also, das sieht doch eigentlich schon mal ganz okay aus.
Kann man das noch rund machen?
Kann man sagen...
Kann man irgendwie sagen...
Border.
Radius.
Hey, das funktioniert.
Guck mal, jetzt ist es rund.
Nice.
Ey, die sieht gar nicht mal so doof aus, die Scrollbar.
Das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Wobei, man sagen muss, die Höhe sollten wir hier noch...
Kann man hier die Höhe festlegen?
Ey, das ist, das ist doch echt ganz in Ordnung.
Das ist doch echt ganz okay.
Das lasse ich so.
Fertig.
Das ist top, top Scrollbar.
Ein bisschen kleiner könnten wir es noch machen.
Vielleicht 10.
Weil, also insgesamt, ich will das eigentlich nicht global machen.
Weil hier soll die Scrollbar ja am Endeffekt auch weg.
Ich will hier gar keine Scrollbar haben.
Wartet mal.
Body.
Aber wo machen wir das jetzt?
Scroll...
None?
Nee.
Nee, Overflow ist es.
Overflow Hidden.
Aha.
Weil hier will ich eh nichts scrollen drinne.
Das finde ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt ganz stylisch so.
Das lassen wir so.
Das ist gut.
Weil man könnte vielleicht ein bisschen...
Man könnte ein bisschen noch den...
Wo habe ich das denn jetzt gemacht?
Vor allem, warum?
Wenn ich das global mache, dann sollte ich es vielleicht nicht hier rein machen mit global.
Im Index rechnest du mit global schon eher.
So.
Was ist da dran so schlimm?
Global setzt ein Tier ab.
So, Background Color.
Das brauchen wir noch gar nicht mehr.
Man kann auch jetzt einfach nur noch Background schreiben, ne?
Was ich nicht verstehe ist,
ich habe den gleichen Hintergrund für den Knopf wie für die Leiste,
aber angeblich sieht man das immer noch, was sehr merkwürdig ist.
So finde ich es eigentlich fast noch besser.
Leute, sollen wir der Leiste den Hintergrund geben
oder den Hintergrund einfach weglassen?
Ich finde es fast schon stylischer, wenn der Hintergrund weg...
Wobei, das sieht man ein bisschen schlecht.
Das sieht man sieht man ein bisschen schlecht.
Sollen wir das mal mal ein Ticken, mal ein Ticken dunkler?
Ah, jetzt, ok jetzt.
Sollen wir mal ein Ticken, Ticken dunkler noch?
Ah, noch dunkler.
Der Teufel.
Ja, so ist gut.
So gefällt mir das eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber was noch für den Extra Style?
Oh, was, was, was für ein Ding?
Ach, Chico ist im Weg. Moment, Chico ist zu dick.
Chico, wo mache ich denn jetzt Chico hin?
Es ist kein Platz gerade für Chico.
Das geht aber, der Chico muss eingeplantet bleiben.
Chico, du musst mal kurz weg.
Chico.
Chico muss mal kurz aus dem Bild.
So.
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz schick, ehrlich gesagt.
Na, das hier unten ist schon mal Müll.
Egal, wir halten uns jetzt mal nicht mit so viel Kleinigkeiten und Optik auf.
Wir basteln jetzt mal ein paar ordentliche Funktionen noch,
weil das muss ja irgendwann mal fertig werden.
Was, Hover, Webkit, Scrollbar?
Ok, Moment, das mache ich jetzt.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was das macht, aber nachdem es CSS ist, kann es nichts Schlimmes machen.
Und jetzt?
Ich sehe da nichts.
Mach mal 20 Pixel.
Ach hier doch, 20 Pixel.
Ah, ja, aber ich will doch nicht, dass es breiter wird, wenn ich hover.
Oder will ich das?
Nee, guck mal, dann scale der ganze Content so hässlich rum.
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist doof.
Da warpt der ganze Content.
Muss ich das einfach so machen?
Track hover.
So?
Nee.
Geht auch nicht.
Egal, das ist nur sinnlose Optik, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Wir machen jetzt einmal einen Ticken breiter, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen klein.
Nicht Borderradius, null.
Wo ist die Breite?
So ist gut, so gefällt mir das.
So, gut, jetzt machen wir mal was Sinnvolles.
Wir malen jetzt im Hintergrund, dass ihr die Labelgröße checkt.
Hier sind die richtigen CSS Professionals, die CSS Consultants sind im Chat.
Ich mach das jetzt nochmal eben, das muss ich nämlich einfach nur Copy Pasten.
Hatte ich nicht sowas eben gerade schon?
Guck mal, da fehlen sogar die Punkte drin schon, das kann ja was werden hier.
Treehead Chat heute wieder.
Nicht, dass ich es besser wüsste oder so.
Die CSS Consultants schlagen zu.
So, jetzt haben wir das.
Jetzt machen wir mal was Sinnvolles, und zwar im Hintergrund.
So, das muss weg, das muss weg, dass ich ein bisschen was sehe.
Im Hintergrund, was ich haben will ist, anstatt diesen hässlichen Kreis, den kein Mensch braucht.
Wer braucht diesen komischen Kreis schon?
Wir machen das jetzt so, dass im Hintergrund die Größe, also nicht die Größe, nicht das Label,
sondern quasi skaliert die Größe, die Seitenverhältnisse, jetzt habe ich es richtig verstanden,
die Seitenverhältnisse vom Label angezeigt werden.
Das finde ich ist eine wichtige Geschichte, weil ansonsten hast du keine Ahnung, fängt das Label da an, fängt das Label da an,
weiß man ja nicht, das ist ja Müll, das müssen wir jetzt ordentlich machen.
Ich überlege gerade, wie wir das gescheit machen.
Also, wir machen auf jeden Fall schon mal einen Rectangle anstatt dem Kreis.
Rect, nicht Content, und das ist auch definitiv nicht Traggable.
Oh, jetzt haben wir, weißt du, Radius, Radius.
Warum malt er jetzt kein Rectangle?
Ich habe bestimmt irgendeinen, ach so, ich muss wahrscheinlich Breite und Höhe noch machen.
Keine Ahnung, was weiß ich, 20, 20, aber nur gucken, ob es geht.
Ah, jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir ein Rectangle, Rectangle.
Bisschen zu laut, die Musik.
So, die Fenstergröße muss an den Inhalt, nein, der Inhalt muss sich an die Fenstergröße anpassen.
Jaja, das ist gar nicht so einfach jetzt, gar nicht so einfach.
Also, sagen wir mal, Set, nicht Set, Label Size, also das Label ist 89, oh nee, wir müssen Label Size,
Label, nee, wir müssen Label Width und Label Height oder irgendwie so was machen.
So, jetzt brauchen wir Quick Muffs, Leute.
Ich glaube 39 zu, 39, 36 irgendwie so sind die Labels.
Wir machen mal was anderes, wir machen mal eine extra Methode für, nennen wir mal Set Stage Size,
weil das können wir dann später beim Resizing auch aufrufen.
So, und dann sagen wir jetzt mal Let Stage, also die Stage Breite, also da, wo man dann drauf malt.
So, die Stage Breite ist Window Inner, das weiß ich, weil das hatten wir das letzte Mal schon verwendet.
Also, die Breite vom Fenster, Let Stage Höhe ist Window Inner Höhe.
So, und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt Five Head Time.
Jetzt kommt Five Head Time und ich bin, ich glaube, ich kopiere mir das jetzt von woanders oder von Stack Overflow.
Ich muss das jetzt skalieren, also ich muss jetzt die Label, wo habe ich denn mein Label?
Und wo ist denn hier Label, wo habe ich denn jetzt eben angehört? Also ich muss jetzt, vielleicht ist ja von euch einer so Quick Muffs im Hirn.
Ich muss jetzt, ich kann auch Konst machen, das ist mir, das schockt mich immer, dass ein JavaScript auf vier Varianten,
weil du kannst in JavaScript War da vorschreiben, gar nichts da vorschreiben, Let da vorschreiben oder Konst da vorschreiben.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du auch Static oder sowas da vorschreiben.
Also, wir müssen jetzt, wir müssen jetzt dieses Seitenverhältnis hochskalieren auf dieses Seitenverhältnis.
Also, let scale, ich tue jetzt mal einfach so, als wüsste ich, wie das funktioniert.
In Wirklichkeit habe ich in der Zwischenzeit auf dem zweiten Monitor Stack Overflow gegoogelt.
Ich hoffe mal, das funktioniert so.
Also, das heißt, so, jetzt müssen wir jetzt erstmal, glaube ich, checken, ob das eher höher als, ob das höher als breit oder breiter als hoch ist.
Warum sind das Strings? Das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn. Ja, das sollten keine Strings sein.
Also, wir müssen jetzt gucken, ob das Ding jetzt eher hoch oder eher breit ist.
Also sprich, Stage Breite durch Label Breite oder aber, also das ist jetzt was, was das Kleine ist, oder aber Stage Höhe durch Label.
Also, ich habe grad bei Stack Overflow geguckt, wie das funktioniert, aber natürlich nicht, die schreiben natürlich nicht Stage Höhe.
Die schreiben da X und Y und sonst was hin.
Ja, das ist also quasi richtig, richtige, richtige Konsultengeschichte.
So, das heißt, wir sagen jetzt Stage Breite ist das da und wir sagen Stage Höhe ist, wenn man das richtig, Leute, wir machen auf
im Index HTML, ich mache meinen Overflow raus, weil wenn ich das richtig skaliere, dann habe ich am Endeffekt keinerlei Scrollbars mehr oben und unten.
Wenn ich es richtig mache, wenn ich es richtig skaliere anhand der Fenstergröße, dann sollte ich keine Scrollbars mehr haben, wenn ich es gescheit mache.
Schauen wir mal. Ich habe wieder doppelte Scrollbars.
Okay, Set Stage Size. Das kann ich ja hier schon mal auswählen.
Wo lege ich denn meine Stage an? Set Stage Size.
Wait a minute, das mache ich doch hier schon.
Warum? Jetzt blick ich schnell mal durch.
Moment Leute, Leute, ich mache exakt das Gleiche.
Warum habe ich hier Scrollbars?
Scale wird noch nicht verwendet, genau.
Warum habe ich hier mit Scrollbars?
Ich meine, es soll mir recht sein, ich will keine Scrollbars haben.
Das ist okay, ich mache einfach mal die Höhenbreite jetzt raus.
Perfekt, die Höhenbreite raus.
Also ich habe wirklich...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das so ist.
So, also jetzt haben wir die... Scale haben wir noch nicht gemacht. Scale brauchen wir jetzt für das Rektengel.
Also, ich kopiere mir das mal.
Leute, Leute, wir machen noch was anderes. Let, wir haben hier Always on Top Layer, wir machen Background Layer.
Background Layer, New Layer. Das ist dann nur für unser Hintergrundbild.
Das soll auch keinerlei Events oder sonst was entfangen.
Wir machen mal Background Layer. Background Layer, add das Rektengel und dann Stage add Background Layer.
Also der render das immer in der Reihenfolge von dem, was man hinzufügt.
Das heißt, alles was in diesem Layer ist, wird anhand des Z-Index gerendert und dann nacheinander.
Das heißt, der letzte Layer wird immer an oben drauf gerendert.
Den letzten Layer brauchen wir für den Kram hier. Guck, dass die ganzen...
Wusst ihr das? Wisst ihr, wie Microsoft den Kram nennt?
Wenn ich euch das sage, denkt ihr auch Cacquade, Alter.
Wisst ihr, wie Microsoft das nennt? Diese Füßchen hier. Offiziell.
Ach, ich weiß. Guck mal, ich hab mich vertan. Es muss Stage Höhe sein.
Nee, Microsoft nennt die Dinger Anfasser. Klingt fast schon ein bisschen...
Wie soll man sagen? Fast ein bisschen Gonsexual.
Offiziell heißen die Dinger Windows Anfasser. Anfasser.
Ja, das sind Anfasser. Ich mein, wenn das einen eigenen Wikipedia Eintrag hat,
dann könnt ihr mir glauben, dass das Anfasser heißt.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir auch wieder Scrollbiten. Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Wisst ihr, jetzt check ich das. Wisst ihr, warum wir Scrollbiten haben?
Nee, haben wir nicht. Ich wollte sagen, weil ich oben und unten ein...
Weil ich oben und unten...
Leisten habe, aber...
Das kann nicht sein, die sind fixed.
Ja, warum hab ich denn... Warum hab ich rechts oder warum hab ich... Warum hab ich Scrollbars da jetzt?
Obwohl es exakt so breit ist wie das Fenster.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Die oben ist nicht fixed.
Warte mal, irgendwie kann da minus 40 oder so. Und minus 80, weiß gar nicht, was ich da rechnen muss.
Ja, jetzt ist weg. Ah! Okay, Leute, die untere Scrollbar kommt nur, weil ich die rechte Scrollbar habe.
Wenn die rechte Scrollbar weggeht, geht die untere Scrollbar auch weg.
Äh, wie hoch habe ich den Krempel hier eingestellt? Label Champ. Ach, der hat überhaupt keine Höhe.
12. Da bin ich viel. Aber schauen wir mal, was ist denn 12?
48 Pixel. Das ist aber mega. 10?
Wie hoch ist denn die untere? Fixed.
14. 14 ist die, okay.
14.
Was? 14? Das ist doch Schwachsinn.
Die ist nicht 14. Ergebnislich ist die 14.
Nee, Moment, das ist der falsche. Ah, ich blicke... Nee, das ist... Hä, die ist doch im Leben...
Hä?
Ah, wegen Padding. Da ist noch... Moment, mal hier mal.
Padding weg.
Aber jetzt ist das ungefähr gleich groß.
Ja, jetzt ist es ungefähr gleich groß. 56 Pixel, Leute. 56 Pixel.
Das sieht jetzt zwar beschissen aus, aber wir können einfach sagen, keine Ahnung.
Flex... Nee. Sollte das nicht... Ähm...
Justify Center... Item Center.
So, ja, das ist der Label-Champ in der Mitte. Oder wir können auch Start sagen, dann ist er links.
No. Oh.
Der CSS-Champ ist am Start. So, perfekt. Also, was haben wir gesagt? Höhe?
56 Pixel. So. Z. Hat das was damit zu tun? 56 Pixel? Tatsächlich.
Wenn ich die 56 Pixel abziehe, dann ist alles gut.
Oh. Okay.
Alles klar.
Alles klar. Okay.
Ich... Ich ziehe das jetzt... Ich lasse das jetzt so.
Mach mal 55. Ja. Ist genau die Höhe von oben. 56.
Alles klar. Try and Error.
Label-Champ muss mittig. Nee, da kommen hier oben noch Menüpunkte hin.
Okay. Wunderbar. Excellent. Alles gecheckt. Wunderbar. So. Scale.
So, das haben wir... Setzen wir die Stage. Stage-Preise und so. Alles gut.
Okay. Nachdem wir das ja ausführen wollen, wenn resized wird, muss ich den Hintergrund auch neu malen.
Wobei, muss ich den Hintergrund neu malen oder skaliere ich die Stage nur?
Da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so genau sicher.
Ich könnte ja auch die Stage skalieren.
Wir malen... Wir malen das einfach mal neu. Ich blick da zu wenig durch was.
Okay. Background-Layer.
Wisst ihr was? Den Background-Layer, den machen wir nochmal hier als Variable oben.
Das Ding heißt jetzt in dem Fall auch nicht Layer.
Sondern ich nenne das irgendwie sowas wie... Scheiß drauf.
Selection ist für was? Das ist auch ein Layer. Okay.
Alter, meine Benahmung ist ja wirklich wieder absolut Wahnsinn.
Selection-Layer. Dann haben wir noch ein Background-Layer.
Und das andere sollte ich vielleicht Content-Layer nennen oder sowas.
Rename. Content-Layer.
In das neue Ubuntu schon mal reinge... Du meinst... Sorry Leute, sorry nicht Ubuntu.
Jubantu. In das neue Jubantu schon mal reingeschaut.
Nee. Gibt es da irgendwas interessant, das man sich angucken müsste?
Warum man in das neue Jubantu gucken will?
So. Und wir malen jetzt dieses Rectangle hier oben.
So. Und es funktioniert nicht. Warum nicht?
Oh, weil...
Ach so. Ach, den Layer gibt es ja noch gar nicht.
Ja, das ist ziemlich... Ziemlich Hardcore-Pepega eigentlich.
Ja, das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Dann verschiebe ich das doch einfach, bis es den Layer gibt.
Vielleicht mach ich Set Stage Size. Mach ich dann...
Irgendwo hier unten oder so. Da. Da mach ich Set Stage Size. Sehr gut.
Guck mal, da haben wir jetzt auch unser Rectangle.
Snap ist Dreck. Ja. Snap ist totaler Crap.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man Snap verwendet. Keine Ahnung.
Wie gesagt, von der Idee her ist Snap gar nicht so doof.
Aber es hat halt keine Adoption, sagt man da immer so schön.
Also sie verwendet keine Sau.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob Canonicals selbst den Kram ordentlich supportet.
Und so richtig den Mehrwert sehe ich auch nicht.
Ich meine, ich bin auch kein Fan von Flatpak oder so was.
Also entweder über den distributionseigenen Package-Manager
oder so was wie das Art User-Repo.
Oder im Zweifelsfall stadig den Krempel halt, meinetwegen auch als Docker-Container.
Oder aber, wisst ihr was noch besser ist?
Wenn die App-Anbieter sowas beispielsweise dann, wenn es unbedingt sein muss,
noch als App-Image oder sowas anbieten.
Aber Snap, ich meine Snap an sich von der Technik mag ja sein.
Warum muss es den eigenen Snap-Store und so doofes Zeug geben?
Das weiß ich nicht. Das muss nicht sein.
Okay, also wie machen wir das jetzt?
Jetzt brauchen wir Quick Muffs, Leute.
Massive Sixhead Muffs.
Muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich das irgendwie abgucken kann.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ne, abgucken nicht möglich gerade.
Kein abgucken, das sagt.
Also was mir vorschreibt ist, dass das in der Mitte ist.
Dass ich quasi hier so dieses Label habe.
Also wir fangen nicht bei 00 an, weil 00 ist an der Seite.
Wir fangen an bei, ja das ist doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir fangen an bei Stage Breite.
Machen wir das mal so.
Label, Label Breite, Label Höhe.
So, also Stage Breite.
Nee, Stage, nee, nee, nee.
Also, also, okay, okay.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich habe es, ich glaube, ich habe es gecheckt.
Wir brauchen Stage Breite, Minus Label Breite.
So.
Durch zwei oder irgendwie sowas.
Durch, durch zwei.
Easy.
Massive Fiveheader, Alter.
Jetzt haben wir es raus.
So.
Aber jetzt muss ich das noch skalieren.
Kann ich, kann ich sowas mal, mal scale?
Nicht wirklich.
Das Label ist quer, ja.
Also, die Dinger kann ich dann, die Dinger kann ich dann tauschen.
Klammerfehler.
Ist doch eigentlich gut.
Jaja, mal scale muss, muss doch auch.
Naja, Label, nee, nee, das passt schon.
Das müsste doch sowas sein von der Idee her dann.
Also, die Label Breite mal die Skalierung, aber das passt irgendwie nicht gerade.
Boah, ich hasse sowas, man.
Ich bin da zu, zu, zu Low IQ führen, bis das richtig, richtig, richtig auszurichten, man.
Wir fangen mal, wir machen mal was anderes, Leute.
Wir fangen, wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt mal, wir machen mal Null.
Wir machen Null, Null.
Und dann mal gucken, ob wir wenigstens die, das mit, die Höhe richtig skalieren.
Mal scale.
Okay, das sieht gut aus.
Das sieht, das sieht mal scale.
Das sieht prinzipiell ziemlich richtig aus.
Das, das sieht prinzipiell schon ziemlich gut aus.
Das Label ist seitenverhältnismäßig richtig skaliert.
Okay, gut.
High fat, alles klar.
So, wie kriege ich denn das jetzt, wie kriege ich denn das jetzt in die Mitte?
Ich will hier, sagen wir mal, 20, 20 links und rechts freilassen.
Aber wenn ich 20 links und rechts freilasse, dann muss ich das hier noch abziehen.
Oder sagen wir mal, ich lasse, sagen wir mal, ich lasse 40 frei.
Weil ich will ja ein bisschen was über den Rand schieben können.
Also, sagen wir mal, 40 frei.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt theoretisch noch hier drinnen, das muss ich noch mal klammern.
Dann muss ich sagen, minus 14, im Moment stage.
Ja, stage.
Ach du Kacke.
Minus 40, nee, Center geht nicht so einfach.
Gibt das Sinn, was ich hier mache?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, man.
Scheiß, wir machen jetzt einfach weiter.
So, und jetzt?
Minus 8.
Ah, minus 80, ihr seid 5-head-ish.
Weil es ist das Doppelte, es ist links und es ist rechts.
Ah, 6-head, man.
Wollen wir es nicht vielleicht dann 20 machen?
Das reicht doch, oder?
20, dann machen wir hier 40.
Ah ja, okay, nice.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Das ist fast so, wie wir das haben wollen.
Jetzt muss der Kram nur noch in die Mitte.
So, in die Mitte heißt, wir wollen Y an der Stelle.
Na, das ist doch im Prinzip das, was ich vorhin geschrieben habe, oder?
Stage Höhe minus Label Höhe.
Mal, mal Scale durch 2.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin schon geschrieben habe.
Easy, easy as fuck, Leute.
Easiest überhaupt.
Alles klar, so ist das.
So muss man das machen.
Ist das nicht mittig?
Doch, das ist mittig.
Das ist nicht ganz mittig, oder?
Wie kriege ich das jetzt?
Leute, Moment.
Screenshot, Screenshot-Time.
Screenshot-Time.
Ist das mittig?
Moment, das kriegen wir einfach raus.
Alter, paint man.
Moment, das muss ich jetzt überprüfen, ob das mittig ist oder nicht.
Manchmal, manchmal täuscht sowas, ja.
Ah.
So, Create.
Sehr schön.
So, also ist das, ist das mittig?
Guck mal mal.
Die Kiste passt genau dazwischen.
Das ist genau die Bottom Bar, die...
Na doch.
Nee, das ist okay.
Das ist okay.
Oder die Top Bar ist das.
Also müsste ich jetzt noch minus 56 machen.
Und jetzt ist es mittig, ne?
Alles klar.
Huge Quick Muffs.
Drück mal den Smiley.
Da kannst du dann so Sachen hier einfügen, guck.
So, gut.
Jetzt sieht das natürlich ziemlich kacke aus.
Jetzt das sieht natürlich ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich mittig aus, so wie das jetzt ist.
Also, das heißt, dass wir das jetzt mal ordentlich machen.
Also, wir machen das.
Also, Black, außenrum, Fill, Null.
Ich hoffe, man kann da Null oder None oder so rein.
Okay, dann ist es durchsichtig.
Das ist schon mal gut.
So, Border.
Hat das Ding so ein, hat das Ding Border.
Rekt, Border.
Da wird das Rechteck verdeckt jetzt.
Das ist Absicht, das ist okay.
Das ist ja auch ein Menü, was von unten rausfährt.
Border, Border.
Draw Border.
Ach so, wir haben ja schon.
Ach, das hier ist ja der Border.
Also, dann müssen wir den Border jetzt.
Das habe ich glaube ich gesehen.
Man kann so was hier machen.
Dash, Dash Enabled.
True, True 0W.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Dash, Dash, Dash.
Okay.
Wie geht das?
Wie funktioniert das?
Dash.
Get Set Dash Array for Stroke.
Okay, 10, 5.
Apply Dash.
5, also 10 Pixel Long und 5 Pixel auseinander.
Also, muss ich quasi sagen.
Dash.
Und dann denke ich einfach 10, 10.
Das sieht schon mal besser aus.
Stroke Breite ist viel zu fett.
Ja.
Und jetzt noch.
Let's doch Opacity nochmal setzen.
Keine Ahnung.
0,5.
0,4 oder was?
5.
Ja.
Ja, so ist das eigentlich ganz nice, oder?
Das sieht doch jetzt wirklich aus, wie das man im Hintergrund halt einfach die Größe
angezeigt kriegt.
Das ist doch gut.
Jetzt müssen wir noch gucken, dass es sich skaliert.
Wenn man das war der Gelegenheit zu zoomen.
Wir können auch Maus-Zoom noch implementieren.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so kompliziert.
Maus-Zoom.
Post X noch zentrieren.
Ist doch zentriert.
Alles super zentriert.
Wir müssen noch beim Resize.
Wir müssen noch den Resize irgendwie handeln.
Dich hats verwirrt mich auch.
Macht dir nichts draus.
So, jetzt haben wir hier hinten dieses Teil.
Und jetzt Resize.
Resize.
Hab ich dafür schon was?
Nee.
Window.
Ja.
On.
Resize.
Handle.
Function.
Hallo?
Function, please.
Get.
Nicht get.
Function.
Get.
Nicht get.
Handle.
Resize.
So, da gibt es irgendein Event.
Was ist denn hier jetzt kaputt?
So, und was genau kriege ich bei so einem Resize-Event denn als Parameter übergeben,
wenn überhaupt?
Da, guck mal da.
Nix.
Bei diesem Resize-Event steht Nix.
Sind volles drinne.
Das ist natürlich auch geil.
Theoretisch muss ich jetzt einfach sagen Set Stage Size oder der Resize Observer.
Hey!
Das funktioniert.
Also, es funktioniert fast.
Aber, ist der Res, so portig, ist der Resize Observer irgendwie geiler oder was als das
andere?
Nee, ich will das ganze Fenster, das ist schon okay.
So, Handle Resize, das heißt wir brauchen jetzt Background Layer, Clear oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es sowas gibt.
Nein.
Conver.
Layer.
Gibt es sowas wie Clear?
Clear?
Nee.
Delete.
Weißt du, es gibt doch bestimmt was, den kompletten Layer zu löschen.
Gibt es doch.
Gibt es doch bestimmt.
Destroy ist der ganze Layer weg.
Destroy Children.
Alter, das hört sich jetzt aber schon ein bisschen unanständig an die Methode, oder?
Aber, was willst du machen?
Destroy.
Moment, das ist falsch rum, so rum.
Aha!
Guck mal!
Es Resized!
Massive!
Huge Resize!
Pipeheader.
Alter, ich rede heute wirklich, also ich rede wirres Zeug und wisst ihr was das Schlimmste
ist?
Wenn ich mir früher überlegt hätte, wie redet ein 37-Jähriger, hätte ich bestimmt
nicht gedacht, dass der sagt Resize Pipeheader Alter oder sowas, aber da gab es auch noch
kein Twitch, als ich mir Gedanken darüber gemacht habe, wie redet ein 37-Jähriger.
So, also das funktioniert, ich bin begeistert und wisst ihr was wir jetzt noch für ein
neues Poggers Feature brauchen?
Wir brauchen was zum Rotaten, das muss Rotaten, wir brauchen einen Knopf zum Rotaten und wir
brauchen ein Icon, irgendeine Icon Klasse, dass ich nicht immer SVGs kopieren muss.
So, Material Design, wir brauchen einen Icon für Rotate Alter, wie lang das sucht, das
sind keine guten Icons für Rotate, das ist für Rotate ganz gut, das hier, das kennt
man nämlich, das kennen auch die Noobs, Rotate Label, Chat was meint ihr, File Rotate Left
oder Rotate Left Variant, meint ihr das da oder das da, was ist besser für Rotate, das
kennen die Leute halt vom Device, das wird nicht Resize, was man drauf malt, das ist
wohl richtig, ja, da hast du Recht, das ist natürlich ziemlich doof, das heißt ich kann
das so nicht machen, ich muss das, ich muss das mit Stage Skalierung irgendwie machen,
da bin ich aber zu Low IQ für, so Rotate Knopf, so Rotate, unten links, das da, ach
ich lasse jetzt erstmal, so Function, Rotate, so Rotate müsste doch von der Idee her ganz
einfach sein, das ist in dem Fall dann kein Konst mehr, sondern, darf man in Javascript
sowas machen oder flippen dann alle aus, boah ne, das ist ja abartig, warum schreibe ich
einfach Let noch mal davor, so Rotate sagen wir einfach Label Höhe ist Label Breite und
Label Breite, ach Moment, Variablen tauschen ohne temporäre Variablen Leute, Javascript
lasst mal kurz überlegen, konnte man nicht so machen, Leute, richtig massivster Fivehead
Trick, den habe ich mir gemerkt, weil das ist was man öfters braucht, guck mal, richtig,
richtig, richtiger Fiveheader ist das, Javascript Variablen tauschen ohne temporäre Variablen,
äh, aber es funktioniert nicht, es funktioniert nicht, ah, weil ich auf jeden Fall Z-Stage-Size
machen muss, hey, guck mal, vielleicht sollte ich das da mit ins Z-Stage-Size packen, quasi
direkt hier drüber, guck mal wir können Rotaten, hä, boah das stimmt fast nicht, Leute, Leute
das ist nicht richtig, das, das, das funktioniert nicht, Seite 43, ah, ja aber die Höhe stimmt
auch nicht, die Höhe ist auch Mist, Moment, von der Höhe, ich muss oben und unten abziehen
oder, 56 minus 56, okay, ja, ja, okay, okay, okay, das 56 oben, 56 unten, so und jetzt,
aber das ist scheiße, ich muss das skalieren, ich muss das skalieren, weil, weil jetzt ändert
sich ja auch, wenn ich, wenn ich hier was zoome, die, die Elemente nicht mit, das ist,
das ist doof, okay, 56 minus 56, ähm, so, ich muss den Kram jetzt nochmal machen, Moment,
jetzt muss ich aber gucken, ob es größer ist, also ob es, jetzt muss ich gucken, ob,
ob es breiter als hoch oder höher als breit ist, also ich müsste jetzt wahrscheinlich
sowas hier machen, Label, Breite größer Label, Höhe, wenn Label breiter ist, dann 20, ansonsten
das da, aber nicht für Breite, sondern, nicht für Höhe, sondern für Breite, so und das
umgedrehte da, ach du Scheiße, mein Hirn, Alter, was ist das denn, so und hier unten
das gleiche nochmal, bloß jetzt umgedreht, dass es dann da 20 gibt, fuck, meh, ach scheiße,
das ist JavaScript, ach fuck man, das ist, Moment, Label, ach, ich hab hier zweimal das
gleiche, Sekunde, das ist nicht, das darf nicht, ähm, Stage Höhe und Stage, das muss
ich gucken, Stage, Stage Breite, aaah, aaah, guckt mal, Rotation ist am Start, Label Rotation,
aber das stimmt nicht so wirklich, oder, das stimmt nicht so wirklich, guckt mal, schaut
mal, warte mal, das stimmt nicht so wirklich, guckt mal, guckt mal, guckt mal, das da,
ist doch nicht im Seitenverhältnis richtig, was bei der Breite gehört kein, stimmt, warum
hab ich da überhaupt minus 56 gemacht und da gehört auch kein minus, für, für was
hatte ich da nochmal 56, aber das ist trotzdem noch gleich breit, das ergibt keinen Sinn,
das müsste ich hier, weil das Seitenverhältnis ist ja anders, ja aber das Seitenverhältnis
ist hier anders, mein Label muss anders, sich anders skalieren, das, das, das Seitenverhältnis
vom Label ist ja fest, das Label in meinem Drucker ändert sich ja in der Größe nicht,
wenn, ne, wenn sich mein Bildschirm ändert, boah, ich hasse sowas, ich bin, ich bin da
zu, zu, zu 3-Head für, für sowas, wobei, ist das, das ist größer, guck mal, das funktioniert,
guckt mal hier, das Label, ohne Scheiß, das ist so, das, das ist alles richtig, das Label
und das Label, doch, das ist dicker, guck mal, das ist viel mehr Peppofett, ja, ja, guck
mal, das ist viel mehr Peppofett, das stimmt, ok, ich skaliere das schon mal richtig, leider
ist alles, was wir gemacht haben für die Cuts, weil das nicht mit skaliert, weil der Inhalt
nicht mit skaliert, guckt, wenn ich nämlich Inhalt reinmache, dann, na gut, so kann man
das nicht zeigen, dann skaliert der Inhalt nicht mit, eigentlich müsste der Inhalt mit
skalieren, also eigentlich müsste das, der Skalierungsfaktor von dem, von der Stage sich
ändern, boah, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, das ist mir zu, zu 5-Header für heute Abend,
das ordentlich zu machen, aber es sieht zumindest schon mal, prinzipiell besser aus, ich will
jetzt mal, ich will jetzt irgendwas Sinnvolles machen, was mir auch Spaß macht, anstatt so
komische Quick-Muffs-Rescale-Dinger, ich mein, wir können anstatt hier, also nur von der
Idee her, man könnte wahrscheinlich Stage, Stage Punkt Scale oder sowas setzen, könnte
man nicht einfach, Moment, Stage, das muss ich jetzt mal gucken, vielleicht ist es ja
eigentlich ganz einfach, Stage, das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen, wenn das einfach
funktioniert, Stage, man könnte Skalierung setzen, Scale, so Scale X ist der, Scale Y,
ist das von der Idee her, nicht, eigentlich ganz einfach, dass ich einfach sage, Stage,
Scale X, Scale X und ne, boah, ich müsste jetzt, ich müsste jetzt alte Skalierung und
mir angucken, dann müsste man das hochrechnen auf, auf neue, da bin ich zu, zu 3-Header
für, kannst du nicht einfach die Skalierung und Position von direkt auf, doch, wäre es
möglich beziehungsweise besser, wenn das Kennt, was ich nur, ne, weil vielleicht, vielleicht
willst du ja sowas hier machen, du willst ja vielleicht nur die Hälfte haben von diesem
Icon oder so, also 20, 20 Zentimeter drum herum und außerdem, was willst du drum herum,
das anzeigen, da hat es ja keinen, keinen Sinn im Fullscreen zu machen, chat, vielleicht
ist einer von euch schlau genug, ich krieg das grad eben hier nicht, nicht gebacken,
ich dachte mir, ich könnte irgendwas mit Scale, Scale direkt machen und dann, und dann irgendwie
hier gucken, wie ich das skalieren muss, aber das krieg ich grad im Kopf nicht hin, das,
also diesen Part lassen wir mal so, ne, mit Windows Scalen muss ich auf jeden Fall machen,
das wär doof, wenn ich, aber Mausrad Scale ist schon mal nicht verkehrt, das machen wir
jetzt auch noch, Stage Punkt On, so also nicht Maus Down, sondern, äh, heißt es einfach
nur Wheel oder Maus, Maus Wheel heißt das mal, ich mein es heißt Maus Down, jetzt soll
ich Maus Wheel heißen, so, Maus Wheel und dann würden wir quasi, aber die haben da
ein Beispiel für, Conver, Wheel, Zoom, Zooming Stage, genau, hier, Conver, Zoom, Prevent Default,
Stops Default Scrolling, alles klar, brauchen wir das, ich hab kein Default Scrolling, All
Stage, Pointer Position, wo war das, ey, brauchen wir alles nett, House Pointer, How to Scale,
Zoom In or Zoom Out, Copy Paste, Copy Paste, wobei eigentlich reicht, warum 1 oder Minus
True oder False, ist doch ok, Direction, oh was hab ich jetzt, Ach Event hab ich's genannt,
muss ich allen Ernstes Event, Event machen, dass das funktioniert, so, If, Control Key,
brauchen wir nicht, New Scale, brauchen wir auch nicht, aber die Scale, die aktuelle
Skalierung müssen wir uns merken, Stage Scale, so, If Direction, also wenn die Direction irgendwie,
wenn ich Maus Rad rausscrolle, dann will ich einfach sagen Stage Scale X auf Scale X, ehrlich
gesagt keine Ahnung, ne wahrscheinlich nur X, Scale X, dann sagen wir Minus, Minus 05
oder sowas, so und unten drunter sagen wir Y, und ansonsten scrollen wir in die andere
Richtung, ansonsten haben wir plus 5, und wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht habe,
geht's nicht, warum nicht, weil, weil es nur Wheel heißt, ok was haben sich die JavaScript
Leute wieder dabei gedacht, warum heißt es Maus Down und Maus Up, warum heißt es nur
Wheel anstatt, ich mein gibt's sonst noch irgendein Rad, was man im Browser verwendet
als das Maus, oh, hey guck mal, es skaliert, aber vielleicht ist 0,5 bisschen viel, ja,
das ist gar nicht so übel, ok die Tech Lenkrad, ja ganz bestimmt, guck mal das ist gar nicht
so schlecht, vielleicht machen wir es aber noch, wie ist es mit noch einer Null dazwischen,
dürfte nicht zu krass, nein das ist ein bisschen langsam, 3, ja das ist gut, 4, 4, 4 ist optimal,
bam, ja also hier keine Ahnung, Scale Speed, 0,05, 0,420, ja das können wir, ah ne, den
Führer der Null geht ja nicht, ne 5, 5 ist tatsächlich besser, ja, ey das fühlt sich
eigentlich gut an, noch in der Leiste Anzeigen, ja das sind so Microtunings, Tunings, das
machen wir jetzt nicht, das machen wir irgendwann nochmal, aber Cheesy Pro, danke für den
Tipps ab, so das letzte Mal, wir haben jetzt schon eine Anzeige und wir können zoomen,
übrigens bei dem Zoomen, da stimmt jetzt die Skalierung auch, schaut mal, wir machen
das da oben in die Eck, wenn wir jetzt dahin zoomen, dann zoomt auch das alles mit, als
einzige was ich noch machen muss ist, dass ich das bewegen kann, Stage, wo habe ich denn
mein Zeug hier jetzt, hier, Stage Pregable, und jetzt, ah da oben ist es, ok, nice, und
jetzt können wir auch den Kram zoomen und dann bewegen, einzige was nicht funktioniert
ist, da bin ich gerade für Quickmuffs so blöd beim Resize, deswegen lasse ich das heute
machen, irgendwie ein bisschen was erbaulicheres, erfreulicheres als diesen Kram, so, also was
machen wir jetzt mal für sinnvolle Sachen noch, vielleicht sollten wir das mit dem Text
Insert mal irgendwie ordentlich bedienbar machen, weil so ist doch Mist, wisst ihr was
ich mir überlegt habe Chat, was wir machen könnten, wir müssen ja nachträglich, mal
angenommen jemand fügt Text ein oder jemand fügt ein Bild ein oder so, das muss man ja
nachträglich noch anpassen können, was haltet ihr denn von der Idee, wenn man einfach mal
gucken wie das Usability mäßig aussieht, wenn man irgendwie Edit oder Color, irgendwie
sowas hier nimmt als Icon, wenn man sowas hier nimmt als Icon und wir machen jetzt einfach
unten rechts, also da, da in der Ecke hier, da unten rechts in der Ecke, also ich schieb
das mal in die Ecke da unten, in die Ecke schieb hat man irgendwie was mit MX Auto oder
so, ne, boah wie hat man nochmal was Orientation gemacht im Flexbox, konnte man das nicht so
nach rechts irgendwie alignen, ach ML Auto, ah, ist ML Auto, alles klar, speicherbare Templates,
du kannst deine, du kannst deine Kreationen dann speichern, ja, guck mal, also ich hab
mir gedacht wir machen hier unten nen Knopf, der macht übrigens gerade noch das falsche,
wir machen hier unten nen Knopf, können wir mal Edit oder so, so, wir machen hier unten
nen, ah, wir machen hier unten nen Knopf, wenn man da draufklickt, Edit soll das sein,
dann geht ein, was zum, wie weiß ich, das Edit Menü, das Edit Menü gibt es noch gar
nicht, dann geht hier unten ein, also ne, wir inserten nen Element, sagen wir mal Text,
so und dann hat man nen Edit Knopf für, da kannst du dann so Sachen wie Farben und Zeug
machen, weil dann kannst du nämlich auch mit dem gleichen Menü die Icons bearbeiten
und sowas, weil hier will ich doch kein Edit Zeug noch rein machen, das ist zum Einfügen,
das ist zum Editieren, so und deswegen machen wir mal irgendwie so ein Edit Fenster, das
ist schon mal ganz gute Basis hier tatsächlich, Delete Clear, genau, sowas können wir da
auch rein machen, Delete und Clear und solche Geschichten, ja, so New File, nennen wir das
mal Edit Browser, die anderen Dinger heißen auch Browser, dann heißt das Ding Edit Browser,
so und wir kopieren uns jetzt mal den von Text rein, so und den Text, den passen wir
ein bisschen an, nämlich wenn man auf Insert Text drückt, dann, wir brauchen den gar nicht
mehr, wir brauchen den Text Browser gar nicht mehr, wir sagen nämlich einfach anstatt dass
wir hier Text einfügen, machen wir einfach direkt Insert Text und inserten Default Text
beim Klick da drauf, mehr brauchen wir nicht, warum geht das jetzt noch auf, ich hab das
überschrieben, ah, ich hab nicht gespeichert, so Insert Text, brauchen wir nämlich gar
nicht mehr, Text, Color, Texts, ok, ja einfach Default Text, Text, so, Color, standardmäßig
RGB 000, also schwarz, Textshape, ja funktioniert doch schon, nice, Calibri, nee, irgendwas,
mit Fonts setzen wir uns bald noch auseinander, so, das heißt nicht Textshape, sondern wir
nennen das mal um, in Text Note, genau, so also von der Idee her soll jetzt folgendes
passieren, ich klick hier drauf und der addet einen Standard Text und wenn ich den jetzt
doppelt anklicke oder markiere und dann, oder deselectet das nicht mehr, warum nicht, weil
aus irgendwelchen Gründen dieses Hintergrund Rectangle Events annimmt, das ist natürlich
ziemlich Background Layer, ziemlich bescheuert, man konnte doch irgendwie sowas sagen wie
Listen, Listening, Fonts, das hab ich in der Hilfe gesehen, der liest schon Hilfe,
ne, ah jetzt funktioniert es, guck, jetzt kann ich es anklingen, ohne dass das im Weg
ist, so und wenn man dann Text einfügt und den Text doppelt anklicke, dann geht das Edit
Fenster auf, der sieht alle ein bisschen anders aus, nicht so wie das jetzt, das funktioniert
ja nicht, aber bloß mit dem Unterschied, dass ich das Edit Fenster halt auch für Icons
verwenden kann oder für QR Codes oder sonst was und da kommt auch ein Delete Knopf rein
und so, das finde ich ist eine gute Idee, das sollte man so machen oder dann, weil ansonsten
ist ziemlich vermischt, einfügen, suchen und editieren, ich glaube wir machen so einen
Edit Dialog, das glaube ich schöner, so da müssen wir erstmal sagen, also was haben
wir hier, Edit Browser, den brauchen wir gar nicht mehr, den gibt es nicht mehr, also
machen wir einfach, zack, es sollte jetzt eigentlich standardmäßig das Ding hier aufgehen, was
ist, aber nicht macht, was, warum nicht, ach so, weil Browser Element gar nicht open
ist, das stellen wir mal auf true, dass wir mal was sehen, ok, also dann misten wir das
doch jetzt mal aus, wir brauchen einen Edit Dialog, wie machen wir denn einen gescheiten
Edit Dialog, also im Prinzip so ähnlich wie das hier, also der Icon Browser kommt zu,
der Text Browser kommt auch zu, edit, so alles raus hier damit, import, font, styles, alles
erstmal weg, auch weg, so also, das können wir lassen denke ich, das sind die, ich mein
schön sehen meine Edit Buttons jetzt so wirklich nicht aus, weiß gar nicht, ob es um die so
schade ist, wenn man die rausschmeißt, was habe ich denn hier gemacht, warum habe ich
denn das hier alles doppelt und dreifach drin stehen, Chat, was, warum, warum ist das,
warum sieht das so eklig aus, was habe ich denn da gemacht, so, pass mal auf, pass mal
auf, weg, weg, weg, so, input, weg, so, jetzt haben wir einfach gar nichts, da ist einfach
einfach leer, so, können wir jetzt kurz mal was machen, also, color ID to RGB, in welcher
geistige Umnachtung habe ich mich denn da befunden sowas zu bauen, color ID to RGB, was ist denn
da der Sinn von, ich kann auch direkt den Index nehmen, das schmeißen wir weg, weg,
weg, also, wir machen sowas wie, Colonel Colors... Gibt es nicht bereits Eаетorn für
Text mit Formatierung, ja aber die werden in dem Fall nichtHar wow das 이렇게.
Leute, was ist denn hier los?
Bisschen broken ist das ja schon gerade.
War Refreshen, ne ne ne, an der vm liegt es nicht.
Ich hab den Browser reloaded, jetzt gehts.
Naja Photoshop, Photoshop ist vielleicht bisschen übertrieben.
Du kannst hier Label designen und ausdrucken.
Photoshop ist vielleicht ein kleines bisschen hochgegriffen.
So, gut, also available, ich kann schon mal schreiben, habe ich das jetzt richtig geschrieben?
Available Colors, ok, so Available Colors haben wir, dann brauchen wir Available Fonts,
wir machen das jetzt einfach nochmal ordentlich.
Was haben wir für Available Fonts, wir haben Roboto, Mono, das weiß ich, zum ausprobieren
reicht das eigentlich und eins weiß ich noch, was wir noch haben, Reserif, wieder bei uns
im Chat, Comic Sans gibt es nicht, als Webfont kostenlos.
Ok, Available Fonts, was hatten wir denn sonst noch für Fonts, ich hab jetzt alles rausgeschmissen,
sehr, sehr, sehr schlau.
Welches Linux, mal mal ausrufen und zeichne Linux, da gibt es einen eigenen Clip dazu,
das ist Manjaro mit E3 WM, Toggle Font, ok, so, dann brauchen wir ein paar Variablen würde
ich sagen und wir sollten das vielleicht ein bisschen sinnvoll irgendwie benennen.
Also wir brauchen einmal Target Note, also sprich das, was wir mit dieser Komponente übergeben,
was wir hier gerade angeklickt haben, so, dann brauchen wir sowas wie Selected Text,
Autocomplete, Beste, Selected Color, wer denn verkehrt und was, ah ja, Selected Font, Selected
Font brauchen wir noch, im Prinzip das, was ich hier unten habe, Selected Font und Selected
Color haben wir schon, Selected Font Style, so, wunderbar, New Set, was macht das Export,
das Export ist, wenn du das einbindest an der Stelle, dann kannst du da Sachen als Parameter
übergeben, wenn du das als Export hast, du musst quasi explizit sagen, hier, Selected,
kann das sein, dass ich noch überhaupt nirgendswo ausgewählt habe, wenn ich ein Item anklicke,
also du kannst jetzt quasi Variablen dieser Komponente, wenn sie geladen wird, übergeben,
willst du nicht Icons und Text bearbeiten können, doch, doch, deswegen habe ich es auch Selected
Note genannt, so, wo klicke ich den Kram denn an, dass er Selected wird, hier, irgendwo,
Mouse Down, Selection Layer, hier, also, ok, das heißt wir brauchen dann sowas wie Let
Selected Note und das machen wir an der Stelle, wo ich die Sachen auswähle, rein, Selected
Note, Target, so, und hier oben, warum genau, was ist denn der Sinn von diesem, ok, da ist
tatsächlich sinnvoll, dass da ein Return drin ist, und hier oben sage ich Selected Note
gleich Null, weil das ist, also, what, also das hier ist deselect und das hier ist select,
wenn ich ein Item anklicke, so, Selected Style, deswegen, ok, Lederkram jetzt, nee, warum,
weil Selected Note nicht übergeben wurde, so, ich blicke selbst gerade nicht so genau
durch, ob das Sinn ergibt, was ich hier treibe, aber, ja, achso, das ist, da bin ich mir nicht
sicher, ob man das braucht, aber das hier ist eine Svelteigenheit, wenn du willst, dass
die Reactivity im Hintergrund läuft, also, sprich, dass der die Sachen aktualisiert,
musst du einmal neu assignen, es könnte sein, dass das bei einem Set direkt funktioniert,
ohne dass man das neu assignen muss, das können wir gleich mal ausprobieren, da bin ich mir
aber aus dem Kopf nicht sicher, so, gut, also, dann fangen wir mal an, so, auch diesen ganzen
Crap da unten brauchen wir nicht, also, wir machen uns erstmal ein paar Icons für die
Farben.
Chat, ich hab grad euren, ich hab grad außerdem den Chat aktualisiert, das ist blöd, seh
ich nix mehr, aber ich hab, Moment, ich hab noch ne Tab auf, Pfeifert, ich hab den Chat
doppelt auf, so, das ist gut, ok, also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, wir machen jetzt
unsere Buttons für die, ne, wir brauchen den Input, heck weh, wir brauchen einen Input,
weil ich will ja den Text editieren, Input, der kommt da rein übrigens, der Input glaube,
wenn man das so machen, dass es richtig angeordnet ist, so wie wir das letzte Mal gemacht haben,
Input, Text, so, der sieht jetzt hässlich aus, und jetzt müssen wir das Ding mal irgendwie
ordentlich stylen, also erstmal, dass der volle Breite hat, was weiß ich, dass der links
und rechts ein bisschen Padding hat für den Text, dass der Text ist nur grau, lass mal
hier testen, ja, sieht man nicht, dementsprechend brauche ich jetzt den Background, der, den
machen wir auch grau, 900, ne, dann sieht man das nicht mehr, 800, ja, ja, das ist doch
schön, Outline 0, weil es hässlich aussieht, der Tailwind Erfinder sagt ja, er schaltet
auf gar keinen Fall Outline aus, weiß nicht so, warum, der kann nur schwarz-weiß, ja,
der Drucker kann nur schwarz-weiß, aber wir machen Graustufen, wir machen Graustufen,
die man auswählen kann, was man haben will, also Farben weiß vielleicht, falsche Worte,
Graustufen zur Auswahl, so, rounded, das ist aber font, xl, das ist xl, ne, textxl, spellcheck
aus, genau, spellcheck, falls, ah, das sieht schon besser aus, und jetzt nach oben und unten
noch ein bisschen Platz, das sieht doch jetzt schon mal ganz gut aus, also, ja, also ich
kann dir das, ich zeig's dir einfach, guck mal, ich zeig's dir einfach, ich brauch mal
kurz einen Button, so, Button, keqwe, so, wenn wir auf diesen Button klicken, dann hängen
wir irgendwas an selected, sagen wir Toggle Style, wir rufen das da oben auf, ah ne, Moment,
ich hab die Klammern vergessen, so, wir rufen Toggle Style auf mit irgendeiner Klasse hier,
keqwe, ist vollkommen egal, so, wenn ich hier drauf klicke, dann zeigt er das an, so, wenn
ich jetzt mir mal das anzeigen lasse, hier das JSON Stringify Selected Style, so, also
guck mal, jetzt ist es leer, man würde jetzt ja eigentlich erwarten, wenn ich hier drauf
klicke, ich drücke übrigens grad drauf, dann würde sich das irgendwie aktualisieren,
dann würde der irgendwie erkennen, dass der Inhalt von diesem Set, sagen wir mal, von
diesem Array sich ändert, würde man jetzt ja eigentlich ausgehen, davon, weil, warte
mal, ich kann's dir zeigen, Log, Selected Style, oh, wie ging da, JavaScript, Stellz, ging
das so, Selected Style, ja guck, du siehst unten im Log, jedes Mal wenn ich drauf klicke,
adde oder entferne ich hier ein Element drinne, und man würde eigentlich davon ausgehen,
dass sich die Anzeige automatisch Refreshed in der Oberfläche, wenn sich das ändert,
Vue.js zum Beispiel macht das so, die überschreiben intern, irgendwelche Methoden von Array
und Set und sonst was, dass die mitbekommen, wenn sich der Inhalt ändert, so, Svelte macht
das nicht, da musst du neu zuweisen, weil das, guck, hier dieses, oh, ich Refresche
mal kurz, ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht, war ich irgendwas verkehrt?
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass das so funktioniert, ah, kommt das mit Setz
nicht klar, so, guck mal, jetzt entferne ich das, guck mal, jetzt passiert nichts, obwohl
sich der Inhalt ändert, jetzt passiert nichts, obwohl sich der Inhalt ändert, nur wenn ich
neu zuweise, checkt er, dass was passiert ist, das kommt auf dein JavaScript Framework an,
was du verwendest, also in Vue ist es so, die überschreiben intern irgendwelche Sachen,
also wenn du, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie es genau intern funktioniert, aber ich gehe
davon aus, dass es so ist, ja, also in Vue, bei Vue.js machen die es halt irgendwie so,
wenn du Add machst auf dieser, auf diesem Set, dann rufst du nicht wirklich Add auf,
sondern irgendeinen Vue Wrapper von Add, dass der mitbekommt, dass du was hinzufügst
und Svelte hat einfach nur überschrieben, dass ihr mitbekommt, wenn du Assignst, compile
Svelte-Code noch zu Native Plane, ja, was, ja, man könnte jetzt gucken, was er macht,
aber ich fürchte, wir werden da nicht allzu viel, ne, das kann man sich so nicht anzeigen
lassen, wir werden da nicht allzu viel sehen jetzt, ja, also das ist eine Svelteigenheit,
was du sagst, dass er nur bei Assignment diese Reactivity-Rerender-Sache triggert, also es
macht aber genau das, was du sagst, der weiß, dass was drinne ist, der mit der gleichen
Variable sich selbst noch mal zu, also am Inhalt ändert sich nichts, das hier ist nur dafür
da, dass der dieses Neurendern triggert.
Jeder, der den Kram nicht kennt, ja gut, das ist aber nicht bei jedem JavaScript Framework
so, wenn du den Kram nicht kennst, verstehst du die Hälfte nicht, also wenn ich React-Kram
lese, verstehe ich auch nichts, das ist doch normal, deswegen finde ich Vue.js zum Einstieg
gut, ich finde, die haben die beste Kombination aus Magic und relativ klar, was es ist.
Ja, der KQ-Button sollte ja sein, sehr nice Feature, der KQ-Button, ok, der KQ-Button ist
wieder Geschichte, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr, wo ich stehen geblieben muss, ich wollte
Buttons machen, wollen wir einen Placeholder machen, wir brauchen keinen Placeholder, weil
da immer was drinne stehen wird, Famous Last Words, also wir wollten Buttons machen für
die Graustufen, für die Graustufen und für die Frontselection, wenn wir das heute noch
hinkriegen, bin ich wirklich zufrieden, hast du schon mal Nuxt 3 angeschaut, nee, warte
mal, Next, Nuxt, Nuxt ist Vue und Next ist React, gell, ich bringe das immer durcheinander,
aber ich hab mir beides noch nicht angeschaut, Nest ist, was, ja Nuxt ist Vue, Next ist React,
so rum, ja, ja, ja, genau, so ist das, also wir haben einen Input für den Text, ok, ok,
wir haben einen Input, der sieht auch ganz brauchbar aus, ok, als nächstes machen wir
die Buttons für die Graubstufung, also, each, hab ich das noch irgendwo im, aha, erst mal
schön geklaut von mir selbst, so, each, available color, color, diff, ja Frontend ist zu feifert,
für mich auch, jemand als Entwickler zu Hause, ja, ich hab heute auf der Arbeit nicht viel
Proxy, ich bin ja auch kein, ich bin kein Softwareentwickler auf der Arbeit, ich hab
heute den ganzen Tag eigentlich nur sinnvolle Sachen gemacht, wir haben gemietet, dann haben
wir noch mal gemietet, dann waren irgendwelche Leute da und wollten irgendwelche Reverse-Proxy-Sachen
umgestellt haben, wo sich dann rausgestellt hat, die haben den Service selbst kaputt
gemacht, deswegen Proxy, der Proxy nicht mehr, ach, keine Ahnung, ich will mich da eigentlich
gar keine Gedanken zu machen, Kaffee getrunken, nee, ich trinke keinen Kaffee, ich bin wahrscheinlich
der einzige IT-Mensch, der keinen Kaffee trinkt, ok, ich wollte Buttons für Farben machen,
sonst klappt das nicht, Klaas, nee, wir machen das anders, das muss man mit dem Style machen,
Style, Style, Background, nee, so ist falsch, Background, was, kriegt er meine Icons-Auto
completed, aha, nice gg, Background, ja, ich hab Physi gelernt, richtig, 2007, so, Color
müsste das doch eigentlich einfach nur sein, ok, Klaas, machen wir breite Höhe, hey, das
sieht schon mal gut aus, guck mal, die Farbenabstufungen sind schon mal ganz ok, das ist schon mal,
das ist schon mal in Ordnung, da kann ich schon mal mit leben, sollte man das vielleicht
umdrehen, dass Available Colors zuerst anfängt mit Schwarz und dann, naja, ich programmiere
schon länger als ich die Physi-Ausbildung gemacht hab, es ist eh heutzutage kein großer
Unterschied, mal ganz im Ernst, Leute, die das ordentlich können, die können sowohl
als Programmierer sich ein bisschen mit Infrastruktur, Server und vielleicht auch irgendwelchen
Cloud-Funktionen und so was aus, alles auch umgedreht, Leute, die sich da mal hauptsächlich
um irgendwelche operativen Sachen kümmern, die müssen halt auch zumindest den Kram lesen
können, der da programmiert wird, sei es jetzt abgedrehter Kram wie Haskell oder Erlang
oder hast du nicht gesehen, was Lisp, was alles so das Klammern besteht, aber so wirklich
großartigen Unterschied sehe ich da eigentlich gar nicht mehr, heute wird doch auch nur noch
der Fullstack Cloud-Native bis Devops-Engineer gesucht, zumindest wenn man sich mal die Stellenanzeigen
anguckt, was die da alles drinstehen haben, bei meinem Arbeitgeber, wir haben auch so
Stellenanzeigen, wo ich mir denke, so, hä, werbt sich denn da drauf, also das ist schon
mal nicht schlecht, das sieht schon mal prinzipiell aus wie das, was ich haben will, es war bloß,
dass ich das nicht zu eklig, rounded, rounded ist immer gut, wenn was, chat, merkt euch
mal, wenn was kacke aussieht in CSS, das habe ich schon gemerkt, das sieht bei mir
oft kacke aus, moin Patrick, wenn was kacke aussieht, dann rounded border und es sieht
gleich weniger kacke aus, es ist so, rounded border, jetzt habe ich auch, seitdem ich ein
bisschen CSS mache, verstehe ich auch, warum Apple mit diesem rounded border angefangen
hat, mit rounded border sieht einfach alles besser aus, so, also border, dann haben wir
2, oh, warte mal, warum ist das in der gleichen Zeile, da muss ein diff drum an, das soll
nicht in der gleichen Zeile sein, ah, ah, monka, was, what the fuck, was ist das, ich
glaube, wir machen die Input doch mal, ok, ich mache die Input doch mal, doch mal, einzel,
ja, von ks, oder was ist das, bottom, brauche ich nicht, top, brauche ich 2, ja, so, ok,
und jetzt können wir das wahrscheinlich weg machen, ja, ja, ok, ok, das ist besser, richtige
Einschlafmusik, ja, freundin sieht mit rounded border auch aus, ja, rounded border sind prinzipiell
nicht verkehrt, ich, also, mir ist auch klar, dass du auf andere rounded borders anspielst,
aber, man kann auch rounded borders haben, ist halt die Frage, ob die rounded borders
eher rounded sm, md, lg oder xl 2x oder xxxxl sind, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, ich hatte
letztens die Idee, man könnte eigentlich eine super intuitive Messung einführen, ob man
zu fett ist und wie viel man zu fett ist, so, und zwar, wisst ihr, es gibt dann immer
so dinge, body mass index und dann hier vage und dann abziehen und rechnen, also, die einfachste
Variante als Kerl festzustellen, ob man zu fett ist, ist folgendes, man stellt sich
unter die Dusche, gerade, so, und dann guckt man nach unten, und dann gibt es die Möglichkeit,
entweder, sieht man seinen Teil noch oder man sieht nur den Bauch, wenn man nur den
Bauch sieht, dann ist das schon mal ein Ansatz dafür, man ist wohl zu dick und dann kommt
die zweite Stufe, ich habe mir das, ich habe letztens mal 20 Minuten Gedanken darüber
gemacht, ob man ein gutes System draus entwickeln könnte, ja, so, wenn man ihn nicht mal richtig
sieht, wenn man nur nach unten guckt in der Dusche, weil man nur noch den Bauch sieht,
dann macht man seinen Kopf so weit nach vorne, wie geht und wenn man ihn dann noch sieht,
ist man zu dick, aber man kriegt noch nicht einen Herzinfarkt, wenn man seinen Kopf so
weit nach vorne macht, dass man ihn nicht mehr sieht, dann muss man aufpassen, weil akut
Herzinfarkt gefahren, was haltet ihr von dieser Skala, von diesem Verfahren, ich finde das
eigentlich super, ich finde das eigentlich sehr, sehr, sehr, nicht innovativ, sehr intuitiv,
ja, sehr intuitiv zu verwenden, einfach gerade hin, schnell nach unten gucken, aha, man
sieht nicht den Kopf nach vorne, man sieht nur alles ok, Wikipedia Eintritt finde ich
auch der Meinung, das sollte man machen, ja, ob man einen Konsulten konsulten soll, dazu
müsste man erstmal einen Konsulten fragen, der sich auskennt mit dem Konsultieren von
Konsulten, also ich finde das ist eine gute Taktik, das sollte man machen, und man könnte
sogar noch abstufen, so nach dem Motto, je nachdem wie weit man den Kopf nach vorne beugen
muss, falls man noch sieht, wenn man das Ganze nach vorne gebeugt hat, kann man ungefähr
sagen, ok, Hälfte nur mittel zu fett, vorne viel zu fett oder, so wo sind wir jetzt eigentlich
stehen geblieben bei dieser ganzen Geschichte, ich glaube wir kriegen heute nichts gescheites
mehr auf die Reihe, aber ich will auch dieses komisches Edit Dinge hin, sonst wäre das
ja nie fertig, ein Slider, das habe ich mir auch überlegt, aber Slider sieht immer so
aus, als machst du damit die Transparenz und sowas, ich glaube 5 Farben reichen, ja das
funktioniert natürlich nicht immer, aber im Durchschnitt funktioniert das, also wenn
man beispielsweise super fett ist und so einen 35cm Teil hat und man sieht dann ok, dann
funktioniert das nicht, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das im Durchschnitt ziemlich
gut funktioniert, agile Skala, richtig stonks, ok also jetzt haben wir hier unsere Colors,
mit dem Border ist es auch in Ordnung, mach die Farbbuttons breiter, ne ich mach die Farbbuttons
höchstens, höchstens enger zusammen, Diff, außen drum, Bäh, MonkaS, Klaas, ja, ne ne
ne, Cap, 2, ja ok, so und dann machen wir hier oben, machen wir hier unten, hier neben
machen wir noch einen Diff, hat ein wenig zu viel was breites, die sind genauso hoch
wie sie breit sind oder was jetzt, weil wenn ich die breiter mache, sieht doch doof aus,
oder guck mal wenn ich das so mache, doch, kacke aus oder, ne das ist Tailwind, das ist
nicht Bootstrap, vielleicht machen wir die mal 10, 12 ist ein bisschen groß, ne, ja so
ok, so und da machen wir jetzt Buttons hin, für Bold, Italic und Underline, also ich kopier
mir das mal Each, Each, so was haben wir denn, wir haben Bold, Italic, Underline, so und
da brauchen wir im Prinzip genau das gleiche, nur dass wir das anders stylen werden, Color,
da brauchen wir mal weg, Color gibt, man ist nicht S-Color, das ist S-S-Style, so, oder
von Style soll ich es vielleicht nennen, so und, gut, nachdem ich kein Bock habe jetzt
eine halbe Stunde wieder MDI-Icons zu kopieren, einfach, schreien wir jetzt hier einfach mal
rein, mega, mega hässlich aus, null, das können wir so nicht lassen, das ist hässlich,
als fuck, alter, guck mal durch das mal an, null, sich die Möglichkeit nur den ersten
Buchstaben da drin zu lassen, ich will jetzt eigentlich die, die, die, die Funktion bauen
und nicht an der Optik schrauben, ich hab Icons drinne, ich kann Material Design Icons verwenden,
eigentlich, aber ich hab die bisher nur drinne für diesen Icon Browser und nicht als irgendwelche
extra Components, Flex, das muss jetzt erstmal so, so funktionieren, so, Bold, Italic, Andererseits,
so Button, das sollte, das sollte eigentlich ein Button sein, eigentlich sollte das hier
ein Button sein, kein Diff, ein Button, da haben wir nämlich auch Icons, ok, jetzt können
wir noch sagen, Abstand, so, ok, das sieht jetzt schon mal ganz ok aus, mal davon abgesehen,
dass da Text drinne steht anstatt Icons drinne sind in Ordnung, so, ähm, kann man noch sagen
Items Center oder so, nee, Items Center, Just You Are Even, eigentlich alles ordnet wirklich,
eben aber als letzter Schluss, so, und wenn man das jetzt anklickt, ähm, Leute, ich kann
auch nicht mehr denken, wir machen jetzt eine Sache, ich will den Text editieren können,
wenn ich den eingefügt hab, so, Text, ich füg den Text nicht bei 00 ein, das ist pepega,
Moment, Index, Text, was bei 15, 15 füg ich den ein, ich will, ich will den Text editieren,
so, Selected Text, hab ich, hab ich den Text hier jetzt drinne, Moment, hab ich den Text
hier drinne, wenn ich das aufmache, zeig mal her, Log, Target, Note, da, Text, ok, das,
das funktioniert, alles klar, ok, also, wie krieg ich das jetzt hin, dass ich den Text
editieren kann, oh, der ist ja uralt, der Java und sie Scharpitz, danke für den Sub,
das ist jetzt wirklich ein riesen Bart schon, der hat Massive, Massive Bart, ok, also, wir
brauchen jetzt mal zwei Functions, wir brauchen einmal was, einmal was in der Richtung wie
On Target Changed oder so, also sprich, wenn das wechselt, was ich hier anklicke, da muss
ich, da muss ich drauf reagieren, so, und dann brauchen wir sowas wie On, On Data Changed,
so, und da gibt es dann den Text, der sich changed, der Font, der sich changed, der Style,
die Styles, die sich, die sich ändern und die Color, die sich ändert und sowas in der
Richtung, so, On Target Changed machen wir, wenn ich in neuen Notes zugewiesen kriege
und On Data Changed mache ich aktuell, ganz ehrlich, Selected Text, das reicht, zum
ausprobieren sollte das jetzt reichen, so, On Data Changed, wenn ich, ok, wenn das sich
ändert, was ich anklicke, dann will ich erstmal gucken, ob es nicht Null ist, weil wenn es
Null ist, hallo, weil wenn es Null ist, dann sackt das und es würde alles abkacken, also,
auf, wir machen das so, Chat, wie macht ihr das, macht ihr da Klammern drum oder schreibt
ihr das so bei so einem einzeiligen JavaScript, falls es ist, was ich meine, also sprich mit
Klammern oder so, weil so ist, ich meine, warum zwei Zeilen, wenn, wenn nicht, weil man
auch eine Zeile machen kann, immer Klammern für die Sicht, so, das ist das, da gehen
die Meinungen auseinander anscheinend, gut, also, Selected Text gleich, Target Text, so,
wenn ich das richtig gemacht habe, achso, Moment, ich habe da noch kein Binding an meinem
Input, Input, Find Value, Selected Text, ha ha, so, das funktioniert, aber das Editieren
funktioniert noch nicht, das Editieren funktioniert noch nicht, weil ich das noch nicht updatee,
so, und da drinne sage ich jetzt einfach, Target Text, denn Target existiert, Target Text,
Text, so, und jetzt sollte sich, nicht Target, WTF, doch, ne, Target, so, und jetzt sollte
sich das updaten, wenn ich das richtig gemacht habe, Text einfügen, passt, hey, lul, weh,
keck, weh, sind wir uns ja alle einig, dass das eindeutig besser ist, so, jetzt kann ich
Text schon mal, achso, ja gut, wenn ich nicht mehr anklicke, ah, wenn, wenn es den Fokus
verliert, muss es zugehen, natürlich, wenn es den Fokus verliert, muss es zugehen, das
heißt, da wo ich Selected Note mache, muss ich eigentlich noch sagen, ist Element Browser
Open Faults, haha, ha, bam, guck mal, so, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was noch viel, was noch
viel besser ist, wenn wir, wenn wir inserten den Text, dann könnten wir nämlich sagen,
Selection, Layer, Notes, Text Note, und dann ist es gleich Selected, Mist, ich wusste das
mal anders, können wir mal Faults stellen, sonst kann man das natürlich nicht nachstellen,
Faults, das ist noch Faultiger als Faults, aber er eröffnet nicht den Browser, warum
nicht, ah, ich glaube, ich, ich glaube, ich weiß warum, weil ich ihm nicht sage, dass
er den öffnen soll, Edit, so, Text inserten, bam, hey, das ist doch nice, man fügt den
Text ein, es geht direkt, aber da übergibt mich das richtig, oh nee, das muss ich unbedingt
in extra Methode machen, sonst, sonst flieg ich schnell mal durch, Selected Note gleich
Text Note und KS, nee, nee, nice, wenn ich dann wieder rausklick, ist gleich, ist gleich
dicht, jetzt könnte man noch Doppelklick oder so registrieren, Massive Feature, ja,
aber wichtig ist, dass der Kram zugeht, beim einfachen Anklicken, beim einfachen Anklicken
will ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, dass es aufgeht, weil ich will es ja auch einfach
mal vielleicht über den ganzen Bildschirm verschieben, Doppelklick könnten wir uns
noch irgendwie registrieren, Text Note on, das ist so, das ist jetzt, ich glaube so schreibt
man das in Javaclick, äh, in Javaclick, in Javaclick, Dippelklick, Dippelklick, ähm,
Doppelklick, aber im Prinzip das gleiche, oh, ist es, ist es DBL oder DDP, nee, Double
B, ne, DBL, hey, ist Funs, guck mal, Doppelklick, bam, nice, Dippelklick,
ok, das finde ich gut schon mal, das finde ich, guck mal, das wechselt auch, ich kann
sogar wechseln dazwischen und dann, nice, nice, das finde ich gut, Pogchampig ist das
hier, ja, das finde ich gut, so, jetzt müssen wir das natürlich noch machen mit Schriftarten
und wie viel Zeit haben wir noch, weiß nicht, ob ich noch so weit denken kann heute, mit
Farben, mit Farben dürfte relativ, mit Farben dürfte tatsächlich relativ easy sein, also
wenn wir das laden, äh, wenn man das, Moment, muss ich hier überhaupt Nullcheck machen
und Data Changed, ja klar muss ich Nullcheck machen, ich könnte aber einfach auch hier
das gleiche sagen, das ist Manjaro mit E3 WM, ok, so, also jetzt machen wir das für
die Farben, erstmal müssen wir sagen, dass er die Farbe Restored, also sprich, wenn ich
den hier jetzt anklicken und er hat eine andere Farbe, dass er das automatisch einstellt,
also müssen wir initial erstmal sagen, Selected Color, Gleich, so, Target und dann ist das
Address, das habe ich mir gemerkt, Attribute von dem Ding, ne, das müssen wir gar kein
Fragezeichen machen, Fill, müsste es sein, wobei vielleicht ist er auf Fill nicht gesetzt,
weil er scheinbar keine Farbe hat, ja, keine Ahnung, so, und ansonsten Available Colors,
Null, so, dann müssen wir noch einstellen, dass er das automatisch auswählt, was wir
Selektet haben, wo ist die Color, also da können wir jetzt gucken, wenn Selektet, da machen
wir einfach mal einen pinken Rand drum, wenn Selektet, also, Selected Color, Gleich, Gleich
Color, dann sagen wir Border Pink 600, ansonsten Border Grey 100, sollte nicht zumindest eins
jetzt Selektet sein, also eins sollte eigentlich jetzt, von der Theorie, sollte eigentlich
eins jetzt Selektet sein, was haben wir denn hier, Selektet Color, RGB 000, ah, also schwarz,
sollten die nicht eigentlich jetzt einen pinken Rand haben, Moment, Moment, ach so, weil
ich den überschreibe hier, ah, Prinzipiell geht es, oder, jaja, also Prinzipiell geht
es, Selektet Color, Gleich, Gleich, Color, warum geht das nicht, mein, äh, RGB, da steht
es doch, ah, Moment, ja, hä, wo, warum ist das nicht gleich, ok, wir testen es mal so,
Jetzt, Wait a minute, Hä, was zum, ich mein, das da, ist das gleiche, wie das, wie das
da? Moment, was? Ohne Komma? Warum denn da? Warum geht das ohne Komma überhaupt? Wo ist
denn der Sinn davon, dass das ohne Komma ist? Das ist Schwachsinn. Ah ja, das ist schon besser.
Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass das funktioniert, ohne Komma. Gut. So, das heißt, wir können jetzt
tatsächlich die Farbe umstellen, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Also, Data Changed, können wir jetzt
sagen, ähm, ne, Data, Data, ja ja, doch hier, Target Note und dann Fill Color. Ja, wenn man das jetzt
an die richtige Stelle macht. Ups. Okay. Monka, Monka-Verwirrung? Äh, was?
Moment, Available Colors? Warte mal, oder? Wait, Wait a minute. Fünf? Äh, vier? Bin ich? Hä? Was? Oh, das ist zu spät, ich blicke nicht mal durch.
Es ist mir zu spät, ich blicke nicht mal durch. Das ist, das ist zu viel heute. Ich blicke bei
meinem eigenen Shit nicht mal durch. Warum geht das nicht? Das ist bestimmt was super mega Simples.
Ach, weil ich es überhaupt nicht übergebe, Data Changed. Alter, ich, okay, Selected Font, Selected Style, Style Zzzz,
machen wir da draus und Selected Color. Ja, wenn man das nicht übergibt, dann kann das auch nicht
funktionieren. So, schon besser. Zack. Tja, schon funktioniert's und ich kann immer noch keine, keine, weil ich kein, ich kann die
Farbe nicht ändern, weil ich kein OnClick hab. OnClick, ähm, so, das machen wir jetzt aber noch. So, OnClick,
Kommer, Selected Color, Gleich Color. So, und jetzt kann ich die Farbe endlich ändern, Leute. Guck mal, kann ich die, endlich.
Nice. Fock. Was ich ja nicht ganz verstanden hab ist, warum ich die Available Colors,
Null. Ah, Moment mal. Das ist doch verkehrt rum. So. So sollte das sein. Ja, schwarz zuerst und dann Null. So, das ist viel besser.
Das ist viel besser. Nice, ja, richtig nice. So, jetzt kann man das Gleiche hier machen. Kann man die Farbe ändern.
Rausklicken, Edit. So, und jetzt, nachdem wir so viel Zeit haben, Leute, wir machen jetzt noch, wir machen jetzt noch die
Schriftart. Wir machen jetzt noch die Schriftart. Ich hab da nämlich was Cooles gefunden auf GitHub, was ich mal
ausprobieren wollte. So. Und zwar, Font Source hab ich entdeckt. Guck mal. Da kann man die ganzen Google Fonts in sein Projekt
integrieren, ohne dass man Google Fonts verwenden muss. Man kann dann einfach sagen, hier guck mal,
Add Font Source Open Sans und dann einfach importieren. Das ist eigentlich nice. Aber wir brauchen noch ein paar
Gescheite. Wir können auch Google Fonts zum Testen heute nehmen. Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt einfacher.
Das ist richtig nice, ja. Also, wir haben Available Fonts. Die müssen wir jetzt, die müssen wir jetzt rendern.
Available Fonts. Wir duplizieren das jetzt einfach ein paar Mal, damit wir ein paar Fonts zum Reinrendern haben.
Ok. Available Fonts. So. Und da brauchen wir jetzt den gleichen Spaß nochmal. Unten drunter. Also, wir haben jetzt hier.
Wo sind wir denn hier? Da, da muss es nett hin. Unten drunter. So, Fonts. Also, Each. Kopier den Krammer.
Weil Google da nicht tracken kann. Naja, hat mehrere Vorteile, weil Google nicht tracken kann.
Gut, das wäre mir persönlich in dem Fall, weil Fonts jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig wichtig. Nee, der Unterschied ist,
was der Kram beispielsweise noch offline funktioniert. Weil vielleicht bist du ja auch mal nicht online,
wenn du deinen Labelprint verwenden willst oder Google hat Probleme oder was auch immer. Ich meine,
gibt ja keinen Sinn, dass man sowas unbedingt... Warum muss man da nach Google, ja? So, Available Fonts.
Fonts. Mal die Namen hinschreiben lassen. Font, ok. Diff. Ein Diff mit dem Fontname. So, und jetzt Overflow.
Glass. Overflow. Y, Auto. Jetzt haben wir wieder unser tolles Rollbalken, den wir vorhin angepasst haben.
So, oben drüber ein bisschen Platz. Ja. Text Center. Das muss ich immer Flexgedöns machen. Wozu?
Ähm, weil man... Ich mein, die coolen Leute machen so. Nee. Ich mein, ich kann einfach Text Center machen.
Monka Toss Screenshot Tool. Moment, zeig mal, was hast du gefunden?
Ich als Screenshot Tool eigentlich Xshare unter Windows. Äh, nicht Xshare. Jetzt komm ich,
jetzt komm ich. ShareX. Äh, das heißt... ShareX heißt es nicht Xshare. Monka Toss, Alter.
Ah ja, da kann man sich schon mal vertun mit Xshare und ShareX, oder? Wer kennt's nicht?
Wer hat's? Also, ganz im Herzen. Wo das X jetzt ist, da kann man sich schon mal vertun, ja.
Select None wollen wir hier haben. Kann ich nicht auswählbar haben. Full.
Auch Höhe Full. Wobei, das macht er standardmäßig, oder?
Text Cray soll genauso sein wie der Rest, ja. So, und jetzt müssen wir noch irgendwie so was sagen,
wie die Größe von der Schriftart. Also quasi, was nehmen wir denn da jetzt? Text XL und Text 2XL.
Ja, schon mal nicht schlecht. Ist das Welt? Ja, ist es, ist es. Text Center. So, da an den Border Bottom.
Das sieht doch halbwegs in Ordnung aus, was ich hier fabriziert habe, oder? Weil nur,
dass die Schrifte an alle gleich sind. Übrigens, soll ich euch mal einen nice Tailwind Trick zeigen?
Wenn ihr beispielsweise beim letzten Element kein Border haben wollt, könnt ihr einfach sagen Last,
Border, None. Und schon habt ihr überall ein Border unten, plus beim letzten Element nicht.
Massive Five Head, oder? Ich finde das sehr, sehr nice. Bursar, Pointer. Aber sonst noch was?
Padding vielleicht? Ja, das sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus jetzt. Okay, so, und jetzt müssen wir
jetzt einstellen, was der für Fonts haben soll. Also Style, im Prinzip das Gleiche wie hier.
Nur diesmal für Font. Font. Ist das so? Ja. Ist das, ist das richtig? Chat, wie markieren wir
denn am besten diesen Text als Selected? Ich würde ja vorschlagen, wir machen den Texthintergrund
einfach pink. Also die Textfarbe einfach pink. Ja, also dass wir quasi sowas sagen wie hier OnClick.
Aber so. Farben invertieren? Ja, wir können es pink machen. Pink ist glaube ich, passt zum Style.
Selected Font. Gleich Font. Und jetzt sagen wir einfach Class. Warte mal, wie heißt das Ding?
BG Pink? Nee, nicht BG. Text Pink. Ja, Border weiß ich nicht, wie gut das aussieht. Text Border.
Gibt es sowas? Text Border? Krillax, danke für den Sub. Hier, probiere es selber, mache ich.
Gibt es Text Border? Ich glaube nicht, dass es sowas gibt, oder? So, If Selected, Selected Font.
Gleich Font. Hey, guck mal, ist Funst. Nur, dass wir halt immer den gleichen Krempel haben,
das ist natürlich nicht so schön. So, wir brauchen, wir brauchen mehr Fonts. Was haben wir sonst noch
für Fonts? KQ-Font. Megalull-Font. Ob-Font. Der-Font. Ist mir doch egal, wie das Zeug heißt,
zum ausprobieren. Zack. Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so schlecht, Leute, oder? Ich glaube,
das kann man so lassen. Ja. Also, was hatten wir noch mal? Was hatten wir noch mal für einen
Font? Hier. Ähm. Hier, was hatten wir denn noch mal für Fonts? Wir hatten Preserif, wir hatten
EB-Garamont, White 500. Das, das, die installiere ich mir jetzt nämlich selbst gleich. EB-Garamonts.
Gehen wir mal zuerst. Und. Mono. Ich glaube, das war's. Okay. Also, wir brauchen noch irgendwas
Schönes. Ähm. Best-Font-Type. Oder Hand. Handwritten. Handwriting. 20 Best-Handwriting-Fonts.
Indie-Flower. Gibt es das denn hier überhaupt? Comic, Comic Sans gibt's leider nicht. Du hast
Comic Mono oder Comic Neue. Das sieht alles jetzt nicht so. Normalerweise sollte das hier
angezeigt werden drinne. Nicht so geil aus. Indie-Flower. Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
So. Was? Jost. Es gibt ein. Jost. Das ist jetzt kein schöner Handschrift. Mäßig. Josefine Slap.
Lebt da einer von Entwicklern seine Fantasien aus oder? Okay. Stagoverflow. Outline-Effekt.
Tatsächlich. Ah, der macht das mit einem Shadow. Boah, das ist ja mal. Das ist, das ist clever.
Das mit einem Shadow zu machen. Das ist clever. Das, das, das, das merke ich mir mal. Das
finde ich gut. 17 Best-Fonts-Handwriting. Logos. Ach komm, der eine reicht. Wir brauchen
ein paar Fonts noch. Also, Breserif. Wo haben wir den denn? Breserif. Ist er heute eigentlich
da? Den da. So, da hatten wir Roboto. Mono. Weight 500. Weight 500. Da haben wir noch
Gara. Gara. Und? Warte mal noch. Okay. So, jetzt haben wir unsere vier Fonts. Da geht,
da geht noch mehr. Warum benutzt du kein Jan? Weil ich von Jan zurück zu NPM bin. El Metsiri.
Ja, warum nicht? Wir brauchen ein paar Fonts zum Testen. NPM. Install. So, fünf Fonts,
das reicht. Das wird ein Label-Editor. Open. So, also wie heißt das Ding? El Metsiri.
What the fuck? Wie spreit man das so? Oh, super. Font-Font-Family. So. Was habe ich da
vor noch mal installiert? EB, egal, das hatten wir schon. Indie-Flower. Indie-Flower haben
wir noch als als Font. Okay. Ja gut, die sind nicht installiert. So, also, dann machen wir
das doch mal. Import. Wie funktioniert das jetzt? Import. So. Und Import. Das da. Import.
Import. Indie-Flower. Und. Re. So, nice, guck mal. Da haben wir unsere. So, Roboto Mono will
ich allerdings als 500er Font-Weight haben. Das ging glaube auch so. Genau, da kann man
nämlich einfach sagen 500 CSS. Dann sollte Roboto Mono gleich Pepo Fett werden. Jawoll,
habt ihr gesehen? Pepo Mono wurde Pepo Mono, Alter. Roboto Mono wurde Pepo Fett. So rum,
ist auch 500. Indie-Flower können wir vielleicht auch 500 machen, ein bisschen dicker. Aber
gibt es das nicht? Wie? Was ist denn das hier? Node Modules. Node Modules. Less. Font-Source.
Indie-Flower. Was haben wir denn da? 400 nur. Denn gibt es nur ein 400. Aber schwach.
Ganz schwach. So, schauen wir mal, ob es funktioniert. Indie-Flower. Nee, funktioniert nicht. Na gut,
die Auswahl funktioniert. Die Auswahl funktioniert, aber. Ich mach mal den auf 500. Aber das Setzen
von dem Font funktioniert noch nicht. Warum? Weil. Ich glaube ich nirgendswo den Font setze,
ja. Selected Font gleich Target Address Font Family. Oder ansonsten Available Fonts Null.
So. Und dann setzen wir das. Target Node Font Family nach Font. So. Jetzt müsste es eigentlich
klappen. Hey. Das ist Fonts Leute. Guck mal. Ziemlich Pock würde ich sagen. Cute Chat.
Aja ja. Aja ja. Das ist ein richtiger Editor jetzt mittlerweile. Editor. Mein Indie-Flower
ist, könnte ein bisschen dicker sein. Wir können ja immerhin auch noch Bold, Underline, Italic
und so machen. Wartet mal. Ich hatte doch hier irgendwo einen niceen Handschrift-Font.
Lass mich mal kurz nachgucken. Ich hatte irgendwo irgendwas rausgesucht, der sah nice aus. Schon
besser als der Standard Windows Text Editor. Ja man darf von abgesehen, dass ich keine Zeilen
editieren kann. Immer nur eine Zeile. Weil ich hab übrigens auch keinerlei Textumbruch
oder sowas. Also mein Text, der wird einfach nicht umgebrochen. Kann ich kleiner und größer
machen, aber Textumbruch ist echte Wissenschaft für sich. Da musst du dann gucken. Wie viel,
Moment. Vielleicht kann das ja Conver. Conver Text. Da musst du dann so Sachen berechnen.
Wie ist Multiline? Ok. Ich mein. Tutorials, Texts, Multiline. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Multiline. Ok. Texts, Simple Texts. Ja gut, man kann da von Hand Zeilenumbrüche reinmachen,
aber ja, ne ne ne ne. Das ist nicht so einfach. Also Umbruch zu Calculate ist wirklich nicht
ohne. Wenn du eine Text-Error verwendest anstatt eines Inputs-Fields, macht keinen Unterschied.
Das Input-Field ist ja letztendlich dafür da. Wait a minute. Warum verschwindet das,
wenn ich Backspace drücke? Die Input-Area ist ja dafür da, das hier einzutragen, was
man aufs Canvas rendert. Ah, ich weiß woran das liegt. Backspace, hier guck mal. Ich
lösche alles global, wenn ich Backspace drücke. Da muss ich vorher gucken. If irgendwie. If
doch, ich weiß jetzt mal. If, keine Ahnung. Element Menü, gleich gleich edit, dann machen
wir nix. Achtung. Ey. So wirklich perfekt ist das ganze noch nicht, weil wenn ich jetzt
hier rein, ah ne Moment, wenn ich hier raus klicke, geht es ja automatisch zu. Ah, sehr
schön. Ich könnte wahrscheinlich das Event von der Textbox überschreiben und dann sagen
Stop Propagation oder sowas. Also ja, das müsste eigentlich auch funktionieren und
das wäre wahrscheinlich die schönere Variante. Also sagen wir mal edit. Input. Wo haben wir
das Input? Da. Also on change oder sowas. Oder Input. On Input ist es glaube ich. Ne,
ne ich muss on key. Down muss ich glaube ich überschreiben. Ähm, machen wir es mal inline.
Noch zum testen. Event. Event. Event. E. Prevent. Ne Stop. Stop Propagation. Ah, jetzt geht
nämlich das Event nicht mehr rauf. Weil das ist ja in Javascript so, wenn du in der Textbox
bist, wobei wenn ich jetzt hier entfernen drücke, ist auch blöd. Ne, das ist kacke. Muss das,
ich muss das machen, wenn der. Aber in Javascript ist ja so, wenn hier das, wenn die Textbox
das Event auslöst oder als erstes bekommt, kannst und normalerweise, wenn die Textbox
dann fertig ist, das Event handeln, kriegt es das nächst höhere Element, bis es dann
irgendwie im Window ist. Aber du kannst bei dem Event von der Textbox sagen, aufhören
das weiter durchzureichen. Ja, aber das ist trotzdem blöd, weil dann klicke ich hier
unten rein und dann kann ich es trotzdem löschen. Ne, die Lösung im Index ist schon sinniger.
Wenn das Editmenü auf ist, dann kann ich einfach nichts löschen. Ja. Ist glaube ich
sinnvoller. Guck mal, das funktioniert richtig gut.
Convert Text Multi-Line oder Multi-Lines. Da muss ich wahrscheinlich sowas wie, da muss
ich Backslash rein machen hier Text. Ja, ja, aber guck mal, normalerweise, das muss man
wahrscheinlich selbst programmieren. Normalerweise würde ich jetzt erwarten, wenn ich diesen
Text scale, dass der nicht so hässliche Paint-Geschichten macht, sondern dass der jetzt quasi tatsächlich
anpasst, wie viel Text da rein, aber das ist mir zu viel. Gibt es sowas wie Rap-Lines?
Ist das schon recht? Ah, Moment. Ja, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass er das automatisch
macht. Rap can be word. Mach mal, was dann passiert? Nix. Das ist ihm reichlich egal.
Rap. Die Fault ist Word, ne. Ah, man muss Breite und Höhe angeben. Das muss man noch
machen. Ja, das gebe ich nämlich ja gar nicht an. Breite 100. Ah ja. Okay, es heißt, ich
muss das. Ach, verstehe. Das heißt, ich müsste überschreiben, dass die beim Skalieren, das
kann ich nichts mehr löschen. Alter, das ist die Technik ist noch nicht ausgereift.
Das kann ich nichts mehr löschen. Man kann den Umbruch, kann man den Umbruch von Hand
setzen? Moment. Blablabla. Es geht wahrscheinlich nicht. Den kann man so nicht ohne weiteres
von Hand setzen. Ganz ehrlich, damit müssen die Leute leben. Man kann im Zweifelsfall
einfach zwei Texte machen und gut ist. Scheiß drauf. Das gebe ich mir nicht. Du kannst einfach
hier ein Text machen und noch ein Text einfügen und dann unten drunter schreiben. Keck weh.
So, wenn du einen Umbruch haben willst, wurscht. Machen wir nicht. Das programmiere ich nicht.
Also, wenn es eingebaut wäre, könnte man sich noch mal überlegen, aber ich mache
kein Line Word Wrapping oder so. Das gebe ich mir nicht selbst. By the way, warum kann
ich jetzt nichts mehr löschen? Backspace. Das ist überhaupt nicht auf Edit. Das stimmt
nicht. Das ist gelogen. Aha. Mal gucken, ob es open ist. Auch zusätzlich. Schon spät.
Ich sehe es. Ja, das weiß ich schon spät. Schifft Enter. Nee, nee, nee. Schifft Enter
bringt dir da gar nichts. Das ist ja keine normale Textbox. Das ist ein Canvas, wo Text
reingerendert wird. Muss man kein JavaScript Code handy schreiben? Na ja, doch. Guck mal.
Sieht ziemlich javascriptig aus, oder? Das ist der Code für diesen Editor hier. Ich
finde das übrigens sehr nice, Leute, dass der. Ach ja, ich habe den. Ich habe den Font
gefunden, den ich, den ich meinte, der ganz nice ist und zwar. Berkshire Swash, der Name
allein schon, oder? NPM Install. Berkshire Squash. Swash, Swash, nicht Squash. Was kann
es Welt an erleichtern? Das macht dein JavaScriptzeug übersichtlicher und viele Sachen auch einfacher
im Handling. Du kannst zum Beispiel einfach an dieses Inputfeld schreiben. Wo sind wir
denn überhaupt? Du kannst einfach an dieses Inputfeld schreiben, bind value und dann updates
sich das Textfeld mit dem mit dem Wert aus der Variable. Und wenn du das Textfeld was
reinschreibst, dann updates sich der Inhalte Variable. Dementsprechend kann ich das Textfeld
hier unten was reinschreiben und hier oben rendert es mir Schrift auf das Canvas. NMPM
habe ich noch nicht angeschaut, aber ich weiß, dass das der neueste Schrei ist, weil die
coolen Leute in JavaScript nicht zwei Monate den gleichen Package Manager am Stück verwenden
können. Das ist schon sinnvoll. Das linkt nur noch Packages, anstatt die runterzuladen
oder so was. Jetzt haben wir Berkshire Swash noch am Start. Aber wie gesagt, das macht
noch viel mehr, als das wir hier gezeigt haben. Das Welt ist auch nicht das einzige.
Du hast noch Vue.js, du hast React, du hast meinetwegen auch Angular noch. Das Welt hat
aber ein bisschen anderen Ansatz dadurch, dass das Framework quasi verschwindet nach
dem Bilden. Das heißt, wenn du eine Vue App hast, dann hast du immer noch die ganze Vue-Logik
in deinem Browser. Das hast du bei Svelte nur noch relativ wenig. Der übersetzt quasi
alles, was du machst in Vanilla JavaScript. Das führt dazu, dass Welt-Anwendungen ungefähr
20-30% kleiner sind als eine Vue.js-Anwendung. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das umso schneller
legt die Seite. Das ist schon cool, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als kannst du damit alleine
Leute überzeugen. Wenn die Anwendung kacke wäre und der einzige Vorteil, den sie hätten,
wäre, wir sind 20% kleiner oder 30%, das würden die wenigsten machen. Leute, sagt
mir einen Font, den ich nehmen soll. Hier, guckt da. Da sind die Fonts, die zur Auswahl
sind. Big Shoulders Display. Also manche Font-Namen sind nur wirklich hängen geblieben, oder?
Big Shoulders Inline Display. Sagt mir einen Font, den es hier gibt. Es gibt viele Fonts.
Dann nehme ich den. Was haben wir denn hier noch? Akme. Comic Sans gibt es nicht. Comic
Sans ist ein... Roboto haben wir schon. Comic Sans ist ein Microsoft-Lizenz-Font. Das einzige,
was es gibt ist Comic, Mono. Das sieht aber nicht so geil aus. Und es gibt Comic Neue.
Beides kann man. Comic Mono sieht noch am ehesten nach Comic Sans aus.
Was? Akaya? Akaya Kanadaka. Was für ein Ding? Joa, warum nicht? Barcode. Liebre Barcode
28. Ne, das brauchen wir nicht. Das brauchen wir nicht, weil wir haben schon einen Barcode,
wobei das gar nicht so doof ist, den Barcode so abzubilden. Auf die Idee bin ich noch gar
nicht gekommen. Wir haben die Möglichkeit ein QR... Wir haben die Möglichkeit QR-Codes
zu inserten. Das funktioniert. Ich wollte noch die Zusatzmöglichkeit bieten für Barcodes.
Kann der Drucker überhaupt so fein drucken? So fein wie was? Wie das da? Ne, aber du kannst
es ja einfach größer machen. Aber die Idee, das über eine Schriftart reinzumachen, finde
ich tatsächlich ziemlich schlau. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Install. Ja, Ramond, da
haben wir schon eins drinne. Gibt's den? Gibt nur den da. So, das Bild bin ich mal gespannt.
Text. So, und das jetzt auf Barcode. Äh, was ist die Font-Family von dem Ding? Liebre
Barcode 128. Das ist nice. 0W größer KeckW. Leute, wolltet ihr schon immer mal 0W größer
KeckW wissen, wie das in Barcode aussieht? So sieht es aus. Eigentlich finde ich die Idee
sehr nice. Weil dann muss man nicht... Ich meine QR-Codes kannst du mit Schrift nicht
abbilden, ja? Aber Barcodes. Das heißt, warum sollte ich nicht das Ding hier einfach als
Barcode-Option anbieten, dann muss ich keinen extra Barcode-Knopf machen. Oder vielleicht
mache ich einen extra Barcode-Knopf. Oder ne, den machen wir in den QR-Code-Knopf rein
und dann nehmen wir Liebre Barcode mit dabei. Gibt's auch Binary-Fonts? Wenn es keine Binary
wie heißen? Cairo haben wir noch. Caesar-Dressing. Alles klar. Okay, das sieht sehr altertümlich
aus. Wo ist der Unterschied zwischen den Barcode-Schriften an? Das wird wahrscheinlich für unterschiedliche
Barcode-Typen... Ah, guck mal. Auch nice. Barcode-Text. Okay, das muss ich mir merken.
Das ist wirklich sehr nice zum Barcode-Inserten. Da können wir nämlich ziemlich easy Barcode-Supporten
als Input. Das ist cool. Import. Moment, das probieren wir noch mal aus. Import. Von Family.
Text-Kursiv. Ja, das hab ich noch keinen Support für drin. Das funktioniert. Du kannst
den Barcode nicht mit deinem Handy scannen. Probier das auch mal aus. Also den QR-Code
kannst du mit deinem Handy scannen. Das funktioniert. Mit dem... Barcode? Mal aufmachen, falls ich
was mehr drauf hat. Hab ich nicht. Versuch das mal zu scannen auch gerade. Open. Off-Screen.
Alter. Geh mal nicht auf den Sack. Warum soll ich meine Stadt... München. Alter. Warum
soll ich meine Stadt eingeben für einen Barcode-Scanner? Was ist mit euch los? Ich kann den Barcode
übrigens auch nicht scannen. Ich kann den Barcode auch nicht scannen. Keine Ahnung.
128 funktioniert nicht am Display. Aha. Da haben wir es doch schon. Was funktioniert
denn am Display? Eher ein 13 Text. Ja, QR-Codes funktionieren, aber das ist ja ein Barcode-Reader.
Da sollte das doch eigentlich können. Ich hab ja extra App als Barcode-Reader. Keine
Ahnung. Remove-App, die suckt, ey. Kann das sein, weil ich die vergrößert hab irgendwie
so. Das kleiner sein muss. Egal. Das guck ich mir irgendwann mal anders an. Also. Barcodes
muss ich mal gucken. Ist für Labels schon sinnvoll. Aber Leute, wir haben heute richtig
was auf die Reihe bekommen. Ich mein, guck mal. Wir haben ordentliche Selection für
Farben. Wir haben Edit-Gedöns. Wir können Schriftarten ändern. Und das alles nicht
über dieses Insert-Menü, sondern über ein ordentliches Edit-Menü. Okay. Folgers. Leute,
demnächst geht's weiter. Bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt noch. Ob wir irgendwann
mal fertig werden. Von der Idee her funktioniert eigentlich schon ausgesprochen viel. Ja, das
hab ich mir überlegt, aber die Sache ist halt die, das Ding ist nur schwarz-weiß. Das
einfachste wäre ein Slider. Ein Slider von 256 auf 0. Äh, von 255 auf 0. Dann hast du
alle Grautröne abgedeckt. Aber braucht man nicht. Die Dinger können eh nur sehr rudimentär
Grautröne, indem sie einfach das Label nicht richtig erhitzen und dann so grau-weiße Flecken
bleiben und so. Jaja, die sind nur grau. Ich mein, Farben einbauen ist kein großes
Ding. Letztendlich. Muss man mal gucken. Alles klar, Leute. Schön, dass ihr dabei
wart heute wieder. Ich schau mal schon, ob wir hier irgendjemand hausten können. Der
Krieger spielt wieder sein komisches Hunting Game. Keine Ahnung, was ihm da dran gefällt.
Ich hab mal bei ihm letztens ins Stream reingeguckt, da war er irgendwie im Wald und mit, im Wald
mit der Hirschpfeife und hat Rehe gejagt und so. Also, virtuell. Keine Ahnung, das ist
ein Game, weiß nicht, das schockt mich nicht. Egal. Wir machen jetzt Schluss. Wir sehen
uns das nächste Mal. Bis denn. See you. So, und vorher, bevor wir gehen, Leute, das vergesse
ich das das nächste Mal wieder. Der Chat muss wieder unten hin. Oh, der Chat muss wieder
unten hin und Chico. Warte mal. Chico muss auf den Chat drauf. So ist gut. Chico ist
wieder da. Wir sehen uns, Leute. Bis zum nächsten Stream. Macht's gut. See you.